if you quit on something too soon that
you still love you will regret it for
the rest of your life if you don't love
it anymore quit move on you will never
win doing work that you hate but if you
love it and you move on to something
else you will look back on this day and
regret it for the rest of your life that
you did not see it through most people
spend their entire life living with
regrets don't let that be you the
hardest decision i ever had to make in
my life was being an entrepreneur i
struggled a lot with the decision do i
want to be an entrepreneur and had this
opportunity to make 300 a month and earn
30 of a company versus going to work at
a job that i thought i wanted a job that
i've been preparing myself for that this
is what i wanted to do was in my high
school yearbook of this is where i was
going to be and here it was earning six
figures traveling around the world doing
the investment banking i thought i
wanted to do versus making 300 a month
and owning 30 of a company and the thing
that allowed me to push through and be
an entrepreneur was me saying i don't
want to live with regret that i would
rather no one fail than not know and i
gave myself a year i said i'm gonna give
myself a year to do this i could always
go back and get another job it may not
be the same job probably wouldn't be the
same job may not be as much pay may not
be traveling as much as this job was off
for me to travel but this
entrepreneurial thing this opportunity
that i had i never knew if it would come
back again like i thought maybe this
will never happen to me again and so i
decided to go for it and we struggled
and it was hard but i never ended up
having to go back and get another job
and so if you're at inflection point if
you're thinking about which path should
i take a or b lean in with your heart
stop using your head your head only
understands the world that currently
exists lean in with your heart and ask
yourself which decision will i regret
more if i don't do and then go take that
action i became an entrepreneur because
i didn't want to regret not having at
least tried and a great moment in my
life came a number of years later but
one of the people i went to university
with came back and said evan i went down
that path i became the investment banker
and i hate my life how do i become an
entrepreneur and i looked in his eyes
and i saw the desperation and the
sadness and helped him but also was so
grateful that that wasn't me because it
could have been
need motivation watch a top 10 a believe
nation hey it's nina carmichael and the
chances are you are the most ambitious
person in your circle but you know
you're capable of more and you get a
push by surround yourself with the best
so today let's learn from one of the
best my husband evan carmichael and his
top 50 rules for success enjoy
[Music]
what's the difference between you and
jack ma you both have crazy dreams you
both started with the odds stocked
against you you both started with very
little resources so what's the
difference the difference is that jack
kept believing in his dreams and his
ideas when most people quit and give up
so i actually think you should be on a
mission for life i'm not a big believer
in in five year goals or ten year goals
i think they can help but i think if you
have a five or ten year goal you're
actually thinking small because you
can't predict where you're gonna be in
five or ten years just like the person
you were five or ten years ago could not
have designed the life for where you're
at right now not if you're growing
because the world's changing too quickly
and you're growing and evolving so the
ideas and goals that you had five years
ago may not even be relevant anymore but
the mission stays the same my mission is
belief right your purpose comes from
your pain so my my mission is believe i
want to support entrepreneurs uh because
i struggle so much as an entrepreneur
and i think it's the world's biggest
problem i think the world's biggest
problem is people don't believe in
themselves enough
i think any other problem that you come
up with should have already been solved
by now but the person who could solve
that cancer you know the woman who
should have solved cancer is
an account manager at mcdonald's
because she never won she never tried
going to medical school or two she did
but she didn't believe in herself enough
to chase it down because everybody
around there was telling her that she's
crazy you should be crazy you're doing
something that's never been done before
you're on a mission right and so no
matter how many people i touch with with
all of my content all of my channels
every video that i'm making every
speaking gig every city that i go to no
matter how many people i touch
it's not going to be enough
i think that's great i think you should
have a mission so big that you're never
going to actually accomplish it i think
of ted turner's father who when he made
a certain amount of money became a
millionaire or whatever the number was
he killed himself because he hit his
goal
and and hitting your goal is actually
sad
and so ted turner decided that i'm going
to set a goal so big that i can never
hit it
and that's way more where i'm aligned i
think you should have a mission
something so big that you can never hit
it some people think of that as well
it's too it's too big and so why even
try
and i think of that that starfish
example of the kids at the beach with
the starfish and there's like a million
starfish on the beach and she's throwing
the starfish back in the water so they
can live and the guy walks by and says
what are you doing you can't save all
the starfish and she says i know but i
can save that one and this one and that
one right and so each person that you
help each step you take is is beneficial
it's helpful you never want to actually
hit the goal but you wake up every day
working your face off to try to hit the
goal right to hit that mission and so
that's belief for me and i desperately
hope that you find it for you nobody
wakes up every day and says this is
gonna be the greatest day ever not dan
lok not evan carmichael not tony robbins
nobody you wake up and you're tired and
you have stuff in your eyes and you have
lines on your face from the pillows the
difference between successful people is
that they demand excellence from
themselves to the habits and routines
that they do daily the problem is that
thinking that these people are different
that if you're not waking up with tons
of motivation ready to take on the day
that something is wrong with you the
only thing that's wrong with you is you
don't have the habits that set you up
for success every single day and today i
want to change that so i have a 5s
morning routine that i go through every
single day that sets me up for success
that demands excellence i'm going to
share with you guys today the first s is
sing the fastest way to change your
state is to put on music the fastest way
to go from feeling low energy tired
bored into an energy of i am ready to go
is music
put on the song not that makes you feel
the current way that you're feeling this
is where most people mess up you put on
music for how you're currently feeling
if you're feeling really sad and low
energy you're going to put on really
mellow slow music what does that do it
keeps you in the same state that you're
in
it keeps you exactly where you are what
you want to do is put on the music for
how you want to feel and so i have a
playlist on my main channel called the
believe playlist which is the songs that
i listen to these are the songs that i
listen to every day
they may work for you they may not work
for you there's no perfect song for
everybody there's a perfect song for you
and so build a playlist are the songs
that make you come alive here's the
criteria
if this song came on it would force you
to start moving if the song came on
you'd find yourself doing this if the
song came on you would get out of your
chair and want to move around doesn't
mean you're going to dance like crazy
doesn't mean you're going to start
building up the lyrics that may be you
awesome but if you're a little more
introverted or don't like to dance
something that would make you move
something that would get you at least in
your chair doing this that's what i want
make a playlist and put that on it's the
first thing that you do every single
morning it'll make a huge difference to
setting the tone changing your state and
giving you energy and momentum to start
the day s number two is sun i like
getting outside i think there's
something about getting outside of your
home of your condo your apartment
getting outside getting some fresh air
just being out in nature makes a big
difference getting some getting some
vitamins on your face from the sun
outside but also
signifying that you're you're leaving
your bedroom you're leaving the condo
the apartment the home you're leaving
what happened last night and you're
ready to go off and start the day this
is especially important if you're
working from home because it's easy to
have your you know office right next to
your bedroom or maybe your office is
your bedroom
and carry that bedroom energy that tired
i just woke up i want to stay in bed i
want to sleep energy into your work and
you won't do great things if that's the
energy you're carrying to your work so
having some kind of ritual that splits
up sleeping energy to i'm ready to go
energy makes a big difference and i find
the easiest way to do it is to get
outside and get some sun bonus points if
you're in a condor apartment to take the
stairs instead of the elevator s number
three is soar and this is the most
important thing for me if you only take
one of the five i think this is the most
important one to take
what is the thing that makes you sore
every day what's the thing that makes
you feel alive bold confident what is
that and put it into your morning
routine at some point in your life you
felt bold you felt unstoppable you felt
confident it's happened to everybody the
problem is you don't feel that way
consistently every day
you go through these bursts these
moments of man i could do such amazing
things but then the next day you wake up
and you're a different person you're
back to the i don't know if i can do it
i don't know who am i to go do this
crazy thing that's the problem
so whatever the thing is that makes you
feel like you can come alive that gives
you that boldness and confidence plan it
with intention every single day into
your morning routine for me what i do is
i record a message on my phone to to
instagram to my stories to i put it to
linkedin and twitter right now i'm
putting it everywhere but i need to make
a message so i think of somebody that i
helped yesterday
i think of somebody who commented on a
video who i met in person who i coached
on my instagram live somebody that i
helped yesterday and then i make a
message channeling that person i won't
say the person's name but i have them in
my head
i need to remind myself that the work
that i do is important
it's easy to get lost in numbers it's
it's hard to imagine that two to three
hundred thousand people watched my
videos yesterday that's crazy it's a
wild number right it's wild it's hard to
like what does that even mean i don't
know i'm just sitting here talking to a
camera in my office and two to three
hundred thousand people are watching my
videos it's crazy i need to think down
to the actual person i need to think
about an individual that this matters to
somebody that the work i do really means
something to them
and then i need to record a message and
share that helps me soar and i do it
every day
what is the thing for you
what makes you sore maybe it's watching
the 254 series that i put up every day
maybe it's watching the espresso videos
like this that i put up every day and
some people every day this is part of
the morning routine is watch an espresso
video and i'm humbled to be a part of
your morning routine for other people it
might be meditating they might be
watching a video or might be reading a
book and listening to a podcast i don't
care what the thing is but you have felt
bold unstoppable and confident at some
point in your life what led you to
feeling that way and then demanded of
yourself every day by putting it into
your morning routine the third s is sore
it's the most important one the fourth
has for me is sweat
this is just about being healthy having
a healthy lifestyle and i want to do
something that makes me sweat so whether
it's a hit workout a cardio workout a
weights workout i put that into my daily
routine because i want to bust a sweat
and i want to stay healthy into my
40s which is coming up and then into my
50s and beyond
and then the last s for me is scare i
want to do something every day that
scares me what i'm doing right now is i
take a cold shower so after sweating i
need to have a shower don't want to show
up to work all smelly and so hop in the
shower but right away start turning the
colder and colder and colder and colder
and colder and then right at the very
end i go all the way cold and i freeze
and even just thinking for right now
it sucks
which is the best right you want to do
the thing that scares you every day
you're teaching yourself that i do scary
things so whatever is scary for you
whether it's taking a cold shower
whether it's making a phone call whether
it's sending an email making a video and
posting it doing scary things teaching
yourself getting that out of the way
right from beginning i find really helps
me you are a product of your environment
the people around you are keeping you
exactly where you are and if you love
where you are then keep with those
people but if you want more out of life
if you've got bigger dreams bigger
ambitions then you're going to have to
let some of those takers go now i'm
pretty fortunate that i haven't had any
real takers in a long time in my life
but here's the thing it's easy to
recognize the people who are really
negative in your life and want to
eliminate them but then once you've done
that you'll still find that there's this
middle ground there's these people who
bring you energy who are amazing who
lift you up or awesome be around and
they're people who are negative that you
cut out of your life but then there's
that middle ground of people who they're
just okay
they're not bad they're not great it's
just okay and if you want to raise the
quality of your life if you want to
raise your standards you can't be
hanging around at least spending most of
your time with people who make you feel
just okay so i got back from an event
with tony robbins not that long ago i
think it was last year when i went with
my friend mark draker and
tony at the end of his events how does
he do this firewalk and he lays out
these you know coals these hot burning
coals across the parking lot and you
have to walk uh walk over and he has to
sing cool moss cool moss and it gets you
all excited and amped up to ready to
cross the walk and the idea is you're
doing something that you're afraid of
you're doing something that you're
scared of and to show yourself that
you're capable of doing difficult things
mark and i decided to actually skip the
firewalk because we rushed home and i
did the real fire walk which was in my
life letting go of a number of people
who were just okay it wasn't that they
were bad or toxic or big takers from my
life it was just okay and i realized if
i'm spending all my time on things that
are just okay things people projects
ideas that are just okay that make you
feel just okay right it's good is the
enemy of great if it's really bad you're
gonna let it go but if it's good you
just keep it around and then suddenly
the good becomes your standard your good
becomes acceptable
when did good become acceptable that's
what you need to draw the line in the
sand and see the ideas that are just
good
i need to eliminate from my life the
people that are just good i need to
either eliminate or
spend less time with them to leave room
for the things that are great
extraordinary excellent raising your
standards making you believe more in
yourself and your capabilities
and so coming back from that event not
even it was on that day not even coming
back was on that day i went back to my
airbnb with mark and and i let go of
multiple people in my life and not let
go and say you suck just basically
moving on
and and that allowed me to have a lot
more momentum now now i had a lot more
free time that allowed me to focus on
things that would build me up that would
explode my growth forward and it's been
a crazy
year it's been it's been basically a
year
november 2018 was when that happened so
now it's been almost a full year
uh i guess by the time this video comes
out it's been a full year wow that's
crazy it's been a full year since that
you have to let go of the takers first
and then you have to start thinking
about are the people around you just
good are your ideas just good and slowly
start getting rid of those ones the
projects the tasks look your calendar
what's just good in your life and get
rid of it and leave room and focus on
the things that are extraordinary that
fill you up that build you up to make
you feel amazing because you deserve it
and all of your great work all of your
great activities all of your great
momentum your great impact is going to
come on the other side of doing amazing
things
you will never create something amazing
when you're working on something good
when you feel good and definitely not
when you feel bad
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
i'm really introverted
it doesn't come across right but i am
i'm really introverted uh i don't talk
to people on the airplane next to me is
is justin in the house
there's justin so
i sat next to justin on the airplane
on the way down so you should just tell
it as a theoretical example but i
actually sat next to somebody on the
airplane justin and he's trying to make
small talk
and uh i wasn't trying to be rude just i
small talk makes me anxious like it
gives me crazy anxiety and so i remember
everything he said i remember he woke up
at 4 a.m to catch a 6 a.m flight to get
in at 2 am here with me he likes his
coffee decaf with one sugar and one
cream
[Music]
he has a a black leather tumi bag and so
like i remember all this stuff but we
didn't really talk like that's pretty
much all we talked about on this five
hour flight down from new york to here
and so i i i'm just get super anxious
when doing small talk and networking uh
at the same time i'm scared to make
videos so on my youtube channel right
now have you guys watched some of my
videos on youtube okay decent all right
um
i've got 6 000 videos recorded on my
youtube channel
2 million subscribers 300 million views
all organic i'm the organic guy these
guys are pros that paid ads i'm not
fantastic at that but organic i'm i'm
your guy
and i still get afraid to turn on the
camera in press record
6 000 videos later because because i
want to be an icon too and i want to get
my message out and every video that i
make i wanted to be the best i've ever
done
but i'm still afraid to go out and make
the content
being on stage always gives me crazy
anxiety
right uh i was speaking
a couple weeks ago in whistler and the
speaker before me was david goggins you
know david goggins he's like the most
intense human alive crazy navy seal
ninja
uh and then the guy after me was
football player
peyton manning
peyton manning was out so it's like
david goggins me peyton manning
all right right like
and in all honesty last year when i
spoke at growth
i i had the biggest panic attack of my
life backstage
it's ten minutes before going live
there's this big wind up and lead up and
like just bring me out just bring me out
just i can't wait to go and and my
heart's going like crazy and uh
i just forgot how i was gonna start my
presentation
right i just i just blank have you guys
had that happen we're like you're about
to get on a call or presentation he just
you had it all down you practiced a
thousand times but then you just go
blank
great that was me
just before about to come out and speak
to you know a couple thousand people it
was the first time i was gonna i met
brendan so you know he invited me out we
connected to ethan and the first time i
met him he was doing an interview
backstage and he said hey i'm going to
end my interview because i want to make
sure that i'm watching your presentation
like oh my gosh come on really can't you
just like have a coffee or something
backstage but it's but it's great and
he's going to give me feedback like oh
my god okay i'm ready for the feedback
and so i get on stage and do my thing
but just before that what got me over it
was i took a little peek behind the
curtain
and i saw a bunch of you guys and i
reminded myself that i'm not here for me
i'm here for you
right don't be so selfish
right
yeah you can cut that up
it's not about me it's about the message
and so
the reason why and even this even this
lead up here i'm sitting backstage
ethan's like calming me down because my
heart's going crazy brandon is talking
about the genius ideas that i told him
backstage like oh my god brandon like
the setup
i better deliver
and i tell you this because
i've seen a lot of people from the
arizona event i got stopped a lot of the
past couple days and they said evan i
loved your your speech it was amazing
like oh thank you did you start your
channel where is it it's like oh no i
haven't done it yet
like what that was how many months ago
you loved my speech for what happened
and at the end of the day it's just fear
you can come up with a really logical
reason why you haven't posted yet but
really you're afraid that it's not
perfect you're afraid that no one's
gonna watch it you're afraid that people
are gonna watch it you know you're
afraid you don't know the technology you
don't the gear you know the team you're
just afraid afraid afraid afraid and we
cover it with the reason why we can't do
it right really it's just fear and so i
wanted to share my fear with you because
you might look at dean and brendan and
all these mentors that you have and they
come on stage and they just look amazing
he's like well i can never be like that
but at least for my story i'm always
scared
right like i'm always playing anxious
and nervous i think if you don't have
anything that makes you anxious and
nervous in your life then you hate your
life
right because then you're just staying
inside your comfort zone you know
exactly what to do you're photocopying
your life over and over and over again
and so
life isn't about having no fears it's
about conquering the fears what what
dean said yesterday about having the
courage to jump out of the helicopter
right to be like on the edge here the
helicopter of the plane and say i'm
gonna jump to have the courage to do
that that's what you guys need to do and
why i share it is because the biggest
reason why you guys aren't taking the
action on the most logical opportunity
the biggest opportunity in front of your
face right now is just because of fear
your brain is keeping you afraid and
preventing you from achieving everything
that you want because your brain is
practical it's logical it only
understands a world that currently
exists and if you want to change the
world and you don't learn how to hack
your brain you are going to play scared
for life so i was trying to think about
as i was watching this video what the
when was the last time that i felt
really overwhelmingly scared like i
might not be able to do this i can't do
this i'm not capable
i'm not worthy i don't think i i'm gonna
deliver a good job
and the the only idea that came to mind
recently of a big thing was when i was
speaking at the event in phoenix and i
was invited by brendan burchard and nian
graziosi and i was speaking at their
event and before me was eric thomas on
day one and i was the last speaker on
the last day and i remember
the day of i was pacing backstage about
an hour 45 minutes before the actual
event i'm i'm there i'm pacing i'm
walking back and forth brandon burchard
said he's going to watch my entire
speech and give me feedback after which
only adds to the pressure
and there was a moment where i blanked
out there was a moment maybe
10 minutes before i went on stage i'm
standing backstage and i blank out i
blank like i don't i don't even know
what i'm going to talk what am i going
to talk about right now i don't even
know what i'm going to talk about right
now
it's been a long time since i felt that
level of
desperation insecurity overwhelm because
usually as soon as something as soon as
i hear myself saying this is hard this
is difficult
okay let's go do it the challenge in
this situation was i couldn't just get
up on stage whenever i wanted
and so i'm i'm left sitting there
walking backstage thinking oh my god oh
my god oh my god what if i don't win
what if i don't what if i don't give a
great performance what if i let
everybody down which is my greatest fear
what if i let the audience down and
brendan down and dean down and i told
him i just forgot what i'm gonna say how
do i even start my presentation i'm
gonna wake i'm gonna i'm gonna get up on
stage and just face plant
it was this
i don't know
minute
of just
real
desperation
of feeling like oh my gosh
i'm gonna get up there and suck
i don't know what i'm gonna say
and then the thing that caught me and
i'm so grateful that it did is like the
training the training this is how you
train yourself the training came in i
said what are you doing you're evan
carmichael
let's go
and that may sound
super egotistical
but i think i think the self-criticism
only works when it's based off a
foundation of self-love like i think you
need to celebrate yourself more i think
you need to recognize yourself more not
bragging on social media that you did
some fake goal that you know didn't take
a lot of work but you might get some
accolades for from your friends and
people following you i'm talking about
what do you tell yourself like when you
walk past yourself in the mirror do you
see a rock star do you see a stud do you
see somebody who's gonna go change the
world most people is no and it's and if
it's a yes it's not consistent and so i
think doing the work to tell yourself
that you're amazing i think that should
be a default answer every time you're
nervous is to say i'm
feeling your name i'm
you your name right
evan carmichael let's go
and that
motivated me to then instantly remember
what the thing was it wasn't i forgot
what i was gonna say i was just too
stressed out and blocked that i couldn't
actually get through to what i was
supposed to go out and talk about and so
that shift in my state um by telling
myself i'm evan carmichael let's go
allowed me to connect to and then go off
and and deliver
at least what i thought was a pretty
great uh speech and event you haven't
said that this is the thing this is what
i have to accomplish today this is the
mission that i am on and nothing is
going to stop me if you don't learn to
focus on what's important to you you'll
never do important things and live your
life reacting to what's important to
other people instead so i recently
started a new business with one of my
thought leadership academy students
jeremy he came to my event last year i
was thinking about him on my tour this
year and said i want to start a business
with jeremy around youtube consulting i
get asked a lot hey evan can you check
out my channel hey evan can i work with
you hey evan can i hire you for
xyz looking at my channel giving me
ideas mentoring guiding me and it's just
not the business that i want to be in
but it is a business and so i thought
jeremy jeremy's going to come on board
he's going to do it now when i recruited
him and called him he was not a youtube
expert and i gave him the homework and
said listen if you want to do this
business together it's got to be
important to you i'm halfway through my
trip on my tour i'm coming back in a
month and a half here's what i need you
to know by the end of the month and a
half and i gave him resources i gave him
videos i gave him insights and analytics
and said you need to know all of this
know all of this
and then when i come back if you're
ready we'll start the business
and he did he focused he made it his
priority he knew nothing about this and
all of a sudden he became an expert by
every day all day long grinding to learn
by by researching everybody who is an
expert at this understanding their
methodologies their best practices
looking through all my videos my
thumbnails my strategies all the things
that i've talked about in the past
digesting it kind of like the matrix
when neo's in the matrix and and he now
he can learn kung fu and now he learns
how to fly a helicopter all of that
stuff that's basically what he did
and when it came back in a month and a
half
i put him to the test and said hey let's
do two free calls we'll take two people
from my community and say hey
free free call let's go
and he blew me away with how much he
knew because he focused on it here's a
guy who went from knowing almost zero
to now being an expert
to be able to really help give value to
people
and now when we're looking at new people
coming in
i barely have to do anything
because he already knows what i'm going
to say he already knows he's already
done the work he's done the research
because he spent that time on focused
effort and this is where i think
a lot of people feel like they're never
going to win because you may not have
had the expertise you don't have the
education
it doesn't take long to become an expert
it's just focused work that you're
passionate about
focused work you could quickly become in
a matter of months an expert at
something
if you just focus in on it and dedicate
your life to that thing
that you love
you can easily pass people who are
experts at something who don't love
their thing
but because you're willing to take it on
you're willing to absorb think about
when you went to school
how much of the information you had in
your head
but you had to read over the page four
times
so if you're at the same page four or
five six times because you got lost you
got distracted that's not focused work
because you don't love that thing if i
can't tell the difference between you
and all your competitors then the only
reason why i'm gonna buy from you is
because you have a cheaper price you
don't want to win on being the cheapest
you're amazing you're a genius you have
michael jordan level talent and it's
time for the world to see it you need to
stop hiding so i remember not too long
ago uh i was in new york and i was
meeting with a
former mentor of mine former mentor of
mine four more former mentor well that's
hard to say three times fast former
mentor former mentor former mentor okay
god yes
meeting with a former mentor of mine and
he was asking what my competitive
advantage was and i said believe
say believe what is that like believe i
want people to believe i want to give
people hope i want i want people to have
hope that it's possible and show them
another way it's like hope
you can't be in the hope business
you're selling hope what is that you're
never gonna win off a hope you can't win
off a belief that's just silly and you
know a younger version of me would have
felt
man
i don't know maybe he's right here's
this guy's had so much experience and
done so many things who am i to to judge
i don't know i've never done this before
but
the me who was listening to him was like
this guy just doesn't get it i'm going
to crush i feel i already am i heard him
crush his off believe people stop me say
hey you're the believe guy yeah that's
my mission yo that's what i'm doing
every day that's what i wake up trying
to spread it's the world's biggest
problem and i'm tackling it i'm gonna
make my dent in the universe steve right
i'm gonna go make my dent in the
universe
that's my competitive advantage
and there may be people who don't
understand it and that's okay you can't
let their limited view of the world and
and super limited view of you
prevent you from going off and doing
your thing people think that closing is
a bad word that sales people are slimy
and closing someone on something is good
for you but not necessarily good for
them now some people are like that but
it doesn't have to be you you want to
help people and if you know that they
should be taking action in an area where
they are not their ability to follow
through and listen to your advice is
directly in relation to your ability to
close them if you want to help people
you need to learn how to close i was
really in this same camp you know i i
thought sales people were slimy um i'm
i'm a humble canadian with humble
parents
and never really learned about sales and
techniques and closing because that's
what bad people do you know
and
my my passion is to live a life of
service and i saw my mom do it you know
she's on the wall behind me and all the
great efforts that she went through to
help help humanity and the people around
her and
there was a moment in time i realized
that there was this one moment that this
is when i needed to learn how to get
better at closing this is when i
realized i need to i need to learn this
skill because if i don't it's going to
limit my impact
that i want to build that i want to help
people right it's going to live my
impact so here's what happened there's
an entrepreneur friend of mine he had
this successful business that he was
thinking do i sell it or do i just let
it run on autopilot sell it or let it
run on autopilot because he wanted to go
off and do something else he wanted to
leave the country join a different
business start something new and this
company that he created he was on the
fence whether he should just let it go
and sell it or
go off and try to bring somebody on who
would just run it and he could be on
autopilot mode
the the allure of passive income and
just everything is going to be done for
you automatically right
anyway so i told them you need to sell
the business sell it now sell it while
you still have one foot in the water
sell it while you still have some kind
of care for the company before you hate
it because once you're moving on and
doing other things any any involvement
in this business is going to be such a
drain and the drag for you you can't be
in this thing you need to move on
and he hemmed in hot and i wasn't sure
and i i wasn't good at closing him i
wasn't i wasn't a good enough
communicator to help him through that
decision because i knew that was the
right thing for him
anyway he didn't do it he didn't sell
the business he thought he was going to
live this life you know live overseas
and have this business run on autopilot
and then the business crashed
the business crashed because the person
that he brought in didn't care as much
as he did wasn't the owner like he was
he wasn't there to make sure things
happened when crisis you know did happen
he wasn't super responsive and
eventually the business just fumbled
just just disintegrated just fell apart
even telling a story now brings me back
because
i see that as my responsibility because
he could have sold it and got a good
price it may not have been the price
that he wanted but it's way better than
just watching his business slowly tank
over time
and i knew it was the best answer for
him and i didn't push hard enough i
didn't close him that this is what he
needed to do now you may be watching
saying well that's it's not your
responsibility it's his responsibility
you know he should have known better you
can only do so much and yes at the end
of the day i can only do so much and
it's up to him to be able to make that
decision but i could have done better
right i could have done better
i did not do my best because i didn't
know how to close i didn't learn the
skills
and as a result you know somebody close
to me suffered
and so i decided that i needed to get
better at it i needed to learn more i
needed to improve myself so that with
every entrepreneur that i meet i'm a
little bit better i'm a little bit
stronger i can guide them just a little
bit better if that my improvement in
helping close them
means that they have a massive success
because they decided to take that path
instead of going down the wrong one
because they were afraid or greedy or
whatever other reason
that's amazing
and if you want to influence people it's
the same thing if you want to help
people not just sell your product that
benefits you and doesn't benefit them
i'm not talking about using it for for
nefarious purposes right you want to
help people
you have to learn the closing
through through care through heart
through effort through energy
you have to learn how to close them are
you enjoying evan
evan
you enjoying lying down on the beach
[Music]
evan you look very comfortable
yeah
i gotta do what i gotta do
gotta do what i gotta do how are we
doing evan
good how are you doing
i'm great i'm great nina wants to do
this
how often
a lot a lot like a lot means like once
every three years
no once a week wow once a week
well i'm getting stuff done
let's go
i like the heat
the heat is nice and listen there's heat
anywhere nina goes
water's cold the water is cold evan
look who we bump into
potassium
y'all just take it out
nina got bored so we left
nina got bored
cause i could have napped got bored i
was fine nina got bored till he left i
just want to go for a walk i just want
to go for a walk at the beach
nice
[Music]
why do you get depressed after you
accomplish a goal you celebrate a goal
for five minutes and then you're sad why
is that it's because you had the wrong
goal your goal should not be to climb to
the top of the mountain because the only
spot left is to go down your goal should
be to climb forever you never stop
climbing you're on a mission you're
trying to save the world
stop asking when can i stop you don't
you don't want to you want to climb
forever you don't want to stop not now
not ever because you are on a mission so
one of my biggest fears is the aging
rock star i look at some of these rock
stars who made it big when they're in
their 20s or 30s and then as they get
into their 40s 50s sometimes even 60s
they're still playing which is great
they're still on tour which is awesome
but what are the songs that they're
singing the songs that they're singing
are still the ones that they came up
with when they're in their 20s or 30s
and i can't imagine that i can't imagine
coming up with a video
in my 20s
did i was like in my 20s i was 10 years
ago right april
2009 i was on nine well i'm getting old
april 2009 yes april 2009 so it was 29
when my first video went up great
if i'm still showing that video all the
time if i'm still showing my 40th video
then that's the one that hit i just feel
like
it's such a letdown i mean it's great
that you're still on tour it's great
that you're still being asked to to get
on stage but to sing the same songs over
and over and over again for me i'm not
trying to judge or say that they suck
for me i'm terrified of that i don't
want that to be me i don't want to
think of the video that i made last year
is my best video ever and all i'm going
to do for the rest of my life is just
play that same video over and over and
over and over again i want to climb
forever
i want to challenge myself to come up
with new stories each time whenever
possible making these kind of videos i
want to always push the envelope i want
to always discover new formats i want to
always look at splitting up my channel
or bringing them all back together or
launching a course always always
something new always climbing
i don't see it as this mountaintop there
is no mountaintop you're on the
staircase and you're climbing forever
and you're never going to get to the top
you don't want to get to the top that's
that's sadness that's despair when
you've accomplished everything there is
to accomplish
you hate your life that sucks you
celebrate this is what happens for high
achievers right you celebrate for five
minutes like man we did it and then it's
a big letdown when i crossed 2 million
subscribers on my youtube channel a
million subscribers i didn't want to
celebrate like because the day to day is
a celebration because this is i'd rather
this is celebration this making this
video right here this is my celebration
moment
the process the actual part of climbing
right i'm trying to get better every
single time six thousand videos later
still going when do i stop i don't i
want to make six million videos right
my goal of hitting a billion
entrepreneurs i don't actually want to
hit a billion entrepreneurs
i want to have a goal so big that i
never do it
and so i don't want to be that aging
rock star i hope that when i'm 95 years
old
i may you know not have my mind totally
there my body might be giving up on me
but i'm hoping i'm hoping that i'm still
trying to push the envelope so try to do
more do my best and maybe if i get lazy
complacent slow if i start complaining
you catch me complaining when i'm 95
years old show me this video back show
me this video and say look look
you've become what you said you didn't
want to become
right hold me accountable i think as
soon as you stop growing you're dying
and i think that's why so many people
are unhappy because they've actually
stopped growing a long time ago
and so don't be the aging rock star i
don't want it for me i don't want it for
you either you are staying small because
you're afraid you're afraid of the worst
case scenario coming true losing having
no money and being embarrassed but you
know you're capable of more
you know the way that you're going about
doing things right now is nothing
compared to what you're capable of
unless you lose that scarcity mindset
you're always going to stay small
knowing that you are capable of more
today i'm going to show you how so one
of the easiest ways to get out of your
scarcity mindset is to go from idea to
action as soon as you get an idea you do
something about it and sometimes that
idea often that idea is gonna be too big
too scary too crazy you can't do it who
are you to do this you don't have the
money resources time connections energy
right all of that all of the excuses
that come into your head i like to teach
myself that as soon as i get an idea i
go do
something it may not work but you have
genius ideas trust him go do something
most people either have no idea who they
are and what they want or they do but
they don't have the courage and
confidence to chase it down if you don't
know who you are and what you want then
that needs to be your immediate priority
that's the single most important
exercise that you can do right now if
you know what you want but you're not
chasing after it having more confidence
in who you are will give you the courage
to chase it down either way i'm gonna
give you the answers in this video so
when i first started making videos
i sucked you can go back you can watch
the first one it was april
2009 over 10 years ago i sucked i was
nervous i was shy i was trying to
memorize lines i was sitting down i was
in a suit i was sweating i sucked it was
brutal
and making videos
isn't a logical choice for someone like
me i was introverted i still am i was
afraid of being in front of the camera
i'm looking into the lens and the red
light went on and i went blank i was
trying to memorize my lines just on
paper if you saw me and you said what i
was good at and then put me in
in a situation where i'm making videos
and don't do that that's not for you
here's the thing
i liked it
i wasn't good at it but i liked it
and when you like something with enough
effort enough practice most things you
can be great at it now i'm still on my
journey i still have a long way to go
there's still people i look up to guys
like gary who are crushing it and say i
still have my journey to get better on
but i'm a lot better than i was when i
started
and now i'm off doing keynote speeches
and i'm getting flown out and getting
paid to speak in front of audiences and
i'm growing a channel with 2 million
subscribers and then these sub channels
on top of them it's crazy
because i was doing a thing that on
paper i wasn't supposed to be good at
but i just loved it and that's where the
self-awareness piece comes in
because
you will get an idea to go off and try
something but you'll judge the idea and
you'll say i can't do this because i
don't have x and y and z and i'm not
good enough and tall enough and smart
enough for whatever enough right i'm not
enough
and then you play small for life and you
have uncertainty and you're walking on
quicksand and you end up being pulled
into making somebody else's dreams come
true instead of you watching chasing
your own version of your life down
because you're thinking about all the
reasons why you're not gonna win instead
of the eight why you will so take it
from me a guy who's introverted afraid
of camera
shy doesn't like talking to people
if i can get here
so can you on your dreams i feel like
i'm always spending time with myself i'm
always talking to myself i'm always
reminding myself of how awesome i am of
the ideas that i have are great and i
need to start acting on them i'm very
aware of my thoughts my feelings my
emotions and whenever it's not feeling
right
i switch
and i'll switch on a dime
as soon as as soon as this youtube
channel stops feeling
worth it
not fun anymore wrong energy i'm out and
i'll just leave it behind and move on
and go do something else
i think the same thing of of meditation
i haven't
been able to maintain
and find value in a meditation practice
because i think there's two there's two
sides of meditation and i only recently
learned the difference
the first is about focus and presence
i'm always focused like i'm almost
always focused on presence i'm 85
in the moment focused and and 15
thinking about the future and zero
percent thinking backwards
somebody asked me that question how much
time do you spend past present future in
your day to day like zero about the past
that's why i have a poor memory mark
dreger says i have a poor memory
um i don't i just don't live in the past
so i don't remember most things because
they don't matter to me
i don't they don't apply to me i'm not
i'm not thinking about even even when
you ask me how old i am i have to think
about the year
who cares
i was born in 1980
may 20th 1980.
how is that relevant because you want to
compare your journey to mine that i've
come so this far 39 and you made it this
far at 24 or 54 or whatever i don't know
i just don't think that way i think zero
going backwards and then most of the
time is present and and a little bit
future forward thinking
whenever i'm feeling
stuck
i'll spend more time with myself i'll if
i feel like i need to go for a walk i'll
go for a walk
it's just paying attention to feelings
another conversation i get into with
mark constantly is
i don't remember what
i said but i remember how i felt
and that's mostly where i live just in
the lens of feelings and constantly
talking to myself the reason why you are
not chasing your big dream is because
you're afraid that it's going to fail
you're afraid that it's not going to
work and what people will say about you
and what you will think about yourself
but what's the alternative it's sitting
on your idea for years never taking your
shot because you're afraid and living
the rest of your life in regret knowing
that you had an opportunity but we're
too afraid to take it the way to not
have regrets is to be always taking
action to as soon as you get an idea go
do something about it i had a great
podcast with my friend mark drager a
couple weeks ago a month ago or so where
he was asking me about regret and i used
to always tell this story of
imagine you have a hangnail how much
that hurts and it's all you can think
about when you have a hangnail but if
somebody punches you in the arm you
don't feel the hangnail anymore because
this hurts more right you focus on what
hurts more and suddenly this one doesn't
hurt as much that's how i would use
regret i would always think about
whatever pain that i'm in right now this
thing that i want to do but i'm afraid i
would imagine that this thing is going
to be the best thing of all time that
this video i'm going to make this
feature i'm going to give this clan i'm
going to make is going to be the best of
all time and if i don't do it i'm going
to regret it for the rest of my life for
decades i'm going to regret not taking
action and so the pain of doing the
thing
is the hang nail and the future pain of
regret for decades is the punch to the
arm and so it inflicts so much pain on
me that then i have to go off and do
that thing and i use that for
over a decade
over a decade that's the lens through
which i made decisions and saw the world
but for the past two years i haven't
done that at all i haven't talked about
it i haven't
done it for myself because i talk about
the things that i live
and i'm thinking why why don't i do that
anymore why don't i
use future regret to fuel me
and i found this because i'm always
taking action because as soon as i get
an idea i do something and so i don't
judge the idea i don't say why me i
don't ponder on the idea i don't i don't
just default to strategizing and
thinking i don't think why did i come up
with this why am i thinking about this i
just do it you get an idea you go off
and do it and that's been my mindset for
the past year and a half two years and
as a result
the breakthrough was
you don't live with regret
if you're always taking action on the
ideas that you have you don't live with
regret you might regret some of the
things you end up doing but most of the
things that you regret and other things
done as the action's undone
not undone not taken the action is not
taken you don't regret the things that
you did you get the things that you
didn't do that's most people right there
may be a couple things that you regret
that you did but for the most part it's
the things that you are too afraid to do
that you regret for the rest of your
life and so if you're constantly doing
if you're constantly taking action if
you're always jumping then you don't
have regrets
and it's been an interesting way that i
now see the world and hopefully you can
learn from as soon as you get an idea
you go off and you do something you do
that you won't have any regrets
everything that you want out of life is
on the other side of your biggest fears
you want something more you know you're
capable of something more you'll come up
with a great reason why you can't do
that something more but really you're
just afraid if you want a breakthrough
if you want that dream life you need to
change the way you think about fear or
it will handicap you for the rest of
your life so my biggest fear is
disappointing people
i'm afraid that whatever i'm gonna do i
might disappoint somebody and that keeps
me plain small and so whenever i can
recognize it then i have to go all in
and do it just to show myself because it
allows you to play in a bigger stage
every time and that big fear you have
is still there it doesn't go away you're
just capable of slaying a bigger dragon
each time so
what used to count as disappointing
people or my fear of disappointing
people might have been going to a coffee
meeting and helping an entrepreneur i
remember one time super clearly that i
was booking a meeting with an
entrepreneur and
i was so worried that i was going to
disappoint her that i was hoping that
she would cancel and the story told
myself was i'm too busy i got all the
stuff to do you know the the
realistic
reasons that you can convince yourself
right there weren't stupid reasons they
were realistic but deep down was i'm
just afraid i'm afraid that she's gonna
show up and i'm not gonna give her value
it's a deep fear
and then once i went to go meet her it
was amazing i remember sitting in my car
and said wow like an hour and a half ago
i
was hoping that she was going to cancel
on me and this is the greatest thing of
all time right your biggest
prevent you from living the life that
you want and so i'm afraid of
disappointing people most of the time
you can't catch it i think we play small
by default i think your greatest fear
owns you and is giving you tons of
logical reasons why i can't do that
thing but whenever you catch it
whenever you do watch a catch and say i
think this is just my fear talking
that means it's go time that means you
have to do it just to teach yourself
that you're able to conquer it and move
to a greater level of success making
money is about solving problems that's
the core of business someone has a
problem you see a solution they pay you
to solve it if you're not making money
it's because you haven't solved a big
enough problem yet so let's use my
youtube channels as an example now we
got so many youtube channels it's crazy
i saw a problem i saw a need right i
wanted visual content i wanted to learn
from successful entrepreneurs and i
wanted it done in a visual way i used to
read books a lot because books was the
only way that i was able to get this
information i didn't have mentors to
teach me about business right i had my
parents who were amazing who taught me
how to be a human but i didn't have any
face-to-face mentors that i can go to so
i want the books but i'm a visual
learner i'd much rather see it i get a
lot more by seeing simon talk about a
message than by reading his book i just
do it's how i learn and i think a lot of
people are visual learners and so it's
why i started my youtube channel
i started showcasing successful stories
i started sharing my story as well in
the process and has been that duality
from the beginning of saying here's
where you can learn from successful
people and here's my message as well so
dj plus thought leader mixed together
and here we go and and we've had success
because it solves the problem because a
lot of you have the same problem my
problem is your problem you want more
success around you you want to be
surrounded by these people just like i
did and instead of you having to watch
40 hours of simon sonic content to find
the best and mush it together i do it
for you i actually didn't want to even
have a youtube channel i didn't want to
do this i wish you did this if one of
you did this i would just subscribe be
great be free here we go amazing it was
it didn't exist it wasn't out there so i
did it
and that's the process
you could scratch your own itch you
could you can see what problems other
people have
but success in business comes from
solving other people's problems you
subscribe to this channel because you
like the content because hopefully
hopefully like the content it adds value
to your life it solves the problem it
sets you up for the day that's why i
have this morning espresso series it's
five times a week monday to friday set
you up for the day give you the shot of
energy motivation plus ideas to help you
go off and build your business this is
the problem that i solve what's the big
problem that you solve the trick to
getting yourself into action mode is to
trigger yourself for success triggering
yourself for success means you've taken
the decision making out of it that as
soon as you come up with an idea you
have trained yourself by default into
action mode you see your brain will
always talk you down from things because
it's trying to keep you safe and it only
understands a world that currently
exists that is logical and practical
until you learn to trigger yourself for
success you will constantly doubt your
thoughts your ideas and your actions
this video
is going to help so today i want to talk
about this bag right here a lot of you
leave comments or newer fans of the
channel say why is doritos sponsoring
your videos evan why don't you have a
healthier sponsor don't you know what
bad doritos does to your body you should
be promoting healthy living
doritos is not a sponsor guys this is
this is triggering me for success every
single day and this isn't just some tiny
bag it looks small looking back here but
let me bring this up look at that this
is right next to my face look at how big
that bag of doritos is
i have a strategy
and it's a weird strategy so maybe
you'll love it maybe you won't but i
have a strategy called damn the doritos
i look at this bag so i'm sitting this
is how i'm working right i'm not sitting
i'm standing i'm standing on a
trampoline this is my work space right
now right i'm standing here i'm working
in the court of my eye i got steve jobs
up here and i got i got this giant bag
of doritos all i want to do is eat this
bag all day long i want to destroy this
bag of doritos
look at that giant chip
oh
i'm going to start drooling soon i love
it i want to eat that all day long
this bag is here as a reminder of how
great i am this is the mental
conversation inside my head evan you're
awesome you're awesome for not eating
those doritos every day and i want to as
a reminder people say it doesn't take a
lot of willpower
no it builds for me at least builds the
willpower builds my strength every time
i see that bag of doritos makes me feel
better about myself that i'm not eating
it and i have the strength to keep going
and so i have that here is when you're
on a diet right this is how it began
when you're on a diet
your friends your family the experts
will say get rid of all the junk food
from your house get rid of it all
because
otherwise you'll be tempted and then
you're gonna eat it and then you're
gonna ruin your diet i think that is
actually teaching yourself that you suck
you're teaching yourself i'm a weird
duck you're teaching yourself that you
are not strong enough to be around the
thing and so i need to get it out of my
environment the only way that i can
stick to this thing
is if this other stuff is nowhere close
to me i think you're telling yourself
that you suck i think it's a big crutch
and just like when you break your leg
you have a crutch your ultimate goal is
to not have a crutch is to walk it's to
run it's to be stronger than before
right and so as a step one maybe it's
good right it's a step one okay fine you
broke your leg you have a crutch
you want to get on a diet you're
addicted to junk food get out of the
house awesome but as soon as you go on
vacation as soon as you go to the office
party as soon as you go to new year's
any kind of party you're going to
destroy the food because you've trained
yourself every day that you suck that
you're not capable i think you're a
genius i think you're stronger than you
think
and so i tested it first with myself and
i thought you know what doritos are my
nemesis right i love doritos
oh my gosh she's looking at that bag so
i went to costco and bought the
giant-sized bag of doritos i said i'm
going to put this on my desk all day
long because damn the doritos because
the doritos are stronger than me i don't
think so
right i'm evan carmichael and same thing
for you
that thing that is holding you that's
that's stronger than you i don't think
so remember who you are
remember how strong you are and that's
what this is here for and it's been
awesome to see people now take this up a
friend of the channel uh leron who's
trying to get off of sugar and he has
this uh coffee cup with a saucer and he
drinks his morning coffee and he put two
packets of sugar on the saucer right
next to the coffee so he pours his
coffee has a sugar right next to it and
he just starts drinking it and puts it
down and looks at the sugar packs and
then just drinks the coffee again and
puts it down looks at the sugar packs
and his wife thinks he's crazy and he's
a little crazy too you got to be a
little bit weird duck but but i think
this is actually how you build your
strength
mark drager another friend of the
channel is addicted to the peak freeze
cookies you know the ones that have the
the red on the inside and the cream in
the middle those are among my favorites
too
and so
his ceo when he heard this went out and
bought all these boxes of peak frames
and put it on mark's desk and he opened
it up and this is one of my favorite
things to do when whenever i'm around
doritos or something i really love to to
eat not just say oh put that away from
me don't be around me i can't have that
and not just look at it i want to smell
it
so mark took these cookies brought it
right up here peak free cookies right up
here
oh and you can just see the joy on his
face
jess says he's bringing back memories
and just what those cookies are gonna
taste like when they enter his stomach
and just um goodness everywhere right
the smile on his face maybe a little bit
of jewel coming out you just ah
and then put the cookies down
and walk away
and how great that makes you feel as a
human to say here's one of my biggest
weaknesses of all time bring it
i own you put it down and walk away
right
i think that's how you actually build
strength by doing those difficult things
by triggering yourself for success every
time i see the doritos back i feel
better about myself i feel stronger
about myself and i want you to do the
same thing if any of you are going to
take on that kind of challenge i want to
hear you i want to follow you i want to
i want to see how your journey is going
because it can be one of the biggest
most important life-changing decisions
that you embark on most people focus on
the problem instead of the solution and
that is why they fail i like to say that
there are a million reasons why your
ideas will never work out and only eight
why they will either way you're right so
it's better to focus on the eight your
heroes the people that you look up to
the people that you love and want to be
like right your heroes
all succeeded with less than what you
currently have right now if they can all
do it so can you the only thing in your
way are your excuses so one of the
things that i love most about both my
wife and my team is that they're always
willing to find a way one of the things
that nina loves most about herself i had
her fill out this form maybe two years
ago of like what do you love most about
yourself and at the top was she's a fast
learner she loves learning new things
she loves taking on new challenges and i
love that i love that about her and i
love that in people i think you should
be a fast learner i think you should
love learning i think you should always
be taking on new opportunities right now
on my youtube channel i've split up my
channel into
eight or nine different channels and
then just recently i split them up again
where we launched a top 10 channel just
for the top 10 videos so the top 10
videos aren't on my main channel anymore
and uh then we're doing an everything
channel where if you just want all the
content it's all on one spot so
it's chaos it's crazy my whole team has
to be restructured and everybody's
taking on new projects and
responsibilities and we're supposed to
have a one month transition phase to do
it
that was the recommendation that was
that was the aggressive recommendation
this is have a one month transition
period and for me one month just as
death it's just that i mean i said okay
great one month but then as i'm into it
on the tuesday of like the first week
like guys we need to launch
like this weekend
we need to launch this weekend let's go
right and and there's so many reasons
why it's not gonna work and there's so
many problems and yes we're gonna make
so many mistakes and people aren't
trained properly and there's more work
and we need to
you know we figure out who wants to do
what and how so many issues awesome
let's go
i think about ray for example on my team
who
has been doing all these thumbnails so
i have a i have a set design for my top
10 rules thumbnails that people love and
it's been going like that for years and
i've always been on my team to say
i don't care that everybody thinks their
thumbnails are great they can be better
how do we make them better and so
finally finally after years of testing
we finally found the format that would
win that would that would beat our
original thumbnails and there's minor
differences we zoom in on the face we
got rid of the second logo make the text
bigger minor differences and then rey
has been going back and updating split
tests doing against our old videos we
have 13 1400 different split tests on
our videos it's crazy i think i split
test more than anybody on youtube so
he's going back and updating all the old
thumbnails
and trying to prove a winner each time
and he's maybe i don't know halfway
through
think about it how many videos we have
on the channel we've got 6 000 videos a
lot of them are our top tens
now with this change i found a new
format
we found a new format a new thumbnail
different color scheme different text
different pictures
different logo new thumbnail format and
we found that it's working and so i said
ray
i know you just changed all the
thumbnails
we gotta do it again
he's like this is so exciting let's go
i like i love those guys so much right
where most people what are they they're
gonna complain they're gonna say i just
did all this work on this other thing
right
you don't want to be around people like
that and you definitely don't want to be
that for too many people the problem is
for so many people that's you that's not
even people around you that's you you're
thinking about all the sunk costs that
you put into something you're thinking
about invested so much into this thing
and and now you want me to shift
everything
yep
you need to be on the yep side now you
need to adopt that kind of mindset that
kind of personality that just because i
worked before it doesn't mean it's going
to keep working you find something new
what's better let's go this is what the
whole game is about the number one
biggest thing that you are missing is
momentum you're a genius you've got
michael jordan level talent you are the
best in the world at something but until
you match your effort to your
capabilities your dreams will never
happen so yesterday i had a young
preacher reach out to me on instagram
young
like early teenager reach out to me on
instagram and say hey evan i'm a
preacher i'm trying to get my career
going i want to make youtube videos i
want to spread a message can you watch
my video and give me some feedback
and i love first off i love young
entrepreneurs who are going after it who
are not just sitting there making
excuses as to why they can't because
they don't come from the family they
don't have the right education you know
the right gear to make a video and
there's this guy just takes out his
phone against a simple background poor
lighting doesn't matter right just takes
out his phone starts recording the video
and he's pretty good
right for for a kid who's 14 15 16 years
old he's pretty good he's way better
than i was he's way better than i was
when i started making videos at i don't
know when i started making videos 10
years ago how old am i now 39 29 he's
better at 14 15 16 than i was at 29.
that's amazing i love it but here's the
thing he was only making a video once a
week
so i said i love it man but you gotta
you gotta match your actions to your
missions you gotta keep going if you
wanna be the greatest preacher on the
planet you got to make more content one
to practice right if you're a thought
lead if you're an expert if what you are
creating comes from here
and you just speak it out you need to be
making a video every day every day if
you can freestyle as an artist as a
rapper you should be making a video
every single day now if your videos
require some massive setup not because
it's about the quality of your thought
but it's about fancy stunts or something
that requires a lot more fine but if
it's thought leadership if it's content
that's just coming out of your head
right the quality of your ideas
every single day
once you get better
the more you do it the better you're
gonna get took me 350 videos until i
wasn't completely embarrassed by my own
content right i couldn't watch it back
because i was i was too embarrassed but
oh so bad now as i watch my videos it's
funny whatever nina comes in and she's
seeing me watch my videos i always have
this big grin on my face like i'm i'm
cheering myself on like yeah yeah yeah
that's really good and there's
definitely still tons of room to improve
but
it took me 350 videos to before i wasn't
completely embarrassed and now i'm 6000
or something videos in it's hard to keep
track
your actions have to map your ambitions
so if that's you you've got ideas you've
got knowledge stop coming up with
excuses and make the content film it and
post today and again tomorrow and again
the next day and again the next day and
when you're creating so much content
one again you're getting better because
the the quantity leads to the quality
but two you get less attached to one
video having to be the thing
so often you make one piece of content
one painting one song one video you make
it and then that has to be the thing
you're getting feedback and you
destroyed if it doesn't take off if this
video doesn't take off great
next
right next next next keep going keep
creating you need momentum
so your actions have to map to your
ambitions right whatever idea you have
in your head you want to be the next
oprah of whatever industry great
let's see it let's see it in the work
let's see it in the energy let's see it
in the output that you are creating
every single day the fastest way to
accomplish anything is to model someone
who has already had the same success
that you are after you can go around
trying to figure out everything by
yourself trying to come up with every
new idea yourself and you will slowly
slowly make progress towards your ideas
but until you recognize that success
leaves clues that whatever the thing is
that you're trying to accomplish has
already been solved by thousands and
thousands of thousands of people that
all you need to do is model their
success until you realize that you're
going to constantly stay struggling
making slow progress knowing that you're
capable of more so i first learned the
power of my own success with my first
business where i was struggling i was i
was 19 20
not making any money 300 bucks a month
low confidence filled with self-doubt
not getting results you know i turned
down high paying jobs to do this thing
and own 30 of a company that seemed to
be going nowhere and i told my partner
that i quit and the thing that saved me
when i hit my lowest point was i am not
the first person to try to solve this
problem before maybe my specific
scenario yes biotech software you know
from toronto who's done that before
nobody but a software company getting to
a million dollars somebody's done that
before
how about i just look at their success
and try to emulate it and so the only
person i could think of off the top of
my head was bill gates so i looked at
bill gates and how he got started and
through partnerships and i applied that
lesson to my business and in a short
amount of time had my first deal for 13
and a half thousand dollars i felt like
a rich man you know i felt like holy cow
to go from 300 bucks a month and and
saying i quit to now having a deal in
place for 13 and a half k and more
important the strategy that i could use
again and again again was was life
changing for me
all because i modeled success and that
was again when i was 19 20 so now what
have i done for the past 20 years is
just model success what is my youtube
channel about what is this video about
bottom success why i have these people
behind me it's not for you it's for me i
want to model success they're constantly
pulling me up to a greater spot whatever
problem you have
has been solved not exactly the specific
minutia but by modeling bill gates it
took me 80 of the way
you still have to figure out that final
20 percent but most people are trying to
figure out the whole hundred that's the
problem i was struggling when i was
trying to figure out the whole hundred
all by myself i just come up coming up
with new ideas new ways new innovation
but nothing worked
[Music]
all you have to do is figure out that
last 20
and so look to your heroes look to
potential mentors whether you know them
in person or not they've done it before
they can teach you success leaves clues
you don't have to go through this alone
and you can ramp up your success really
quickly how you think about the problem
is the problem most people are locked
into losing thinking finding all the
reasons why you won't win if you're the
ant think about how you can kill the
elephant if you're the elephant think
about how you can kill the ant the
problem is not the problem how you think
about the problem is the problem so i
used to think that introverts couldn't
win i used to think that to be a good
speaker to have a youtube channel to to
be an entrepreneur that introverts can't
win and for the longest time i hid
behind the faces on my website so before
even starting youtube i started on my
website it was called evancarmical.com
i didn't have a better name at the time
and i profiled different successful
entrepreneurs basically what i do on
youtube but on my website because i
wanted to share the stories model and
success saved my business and i wanted
to make it easier for other people to be
able to get success on their own as well
so learn who's done it apply those
strategies make it work for you and
let's go and so i always hid behind the
faces i remember my first banner i had
howard hughes a big howard hughes
oprah winfrey and a couple other people
and people kept asking me well where's
evan carmichael you know the website's
off your name you're putting this
together what's your story and i thought
well who cares about my story i mean
sure i built and sold my first business
but it's nothing compared to howard
hughes and oprah winfrey's people who've
done great things and it kept coming up
over and over and over again translate
that to my youtube channel
evan carmichael was still the number one
requested top ten and when i first
started doing top tens we did kanye west
shout out to kanye there on the wall and
then a bunch of other people people kept
asking for mine like well what do you
want mine you mean again what have i
done compared to kanye west and i always
hid behind the fact that i was an
introvert and so i don't want to share
my story nobody is interested i'm shy
i'm i'm the wallflower i don't go off
and try to make myself the center of
attention i don't like you know hanging
out with people
and so i had the story that introverts
can't win
it wasn't until i reframed it and
thought you know what introverts can win
in communications because we're better
listeners i'm a great listener as much
as you might think i love talking and
making these videos and seeing the
speeches that i do what i love doing
more than that is listening and i think
that's how you win as an introvert
because it's not about you just sharing
sharing sharing talk talk talk look at
me it's you're trying to help and i've
met some amazing introverts who are on a
huge mission and want to have a big
impact and have to fight with themselves
to get out of the comfort zone and have
the spotlight on them instead of just
being behind the scenes but they're all
great listeners they become great
communicators because they're great
listeners and so the problem wasn't that
i'm an introvert the problem is how i
thought about the problem of being an
introvert every time you say i can't
you're teaching yourself that you suck
because you've quit because you've given
up it's not your fault that you can't do
it it's your work or your school or your
family or all the other commitments that
you have but not your fault nope
nope
nope
change your i can't to either i'm going
to or i choose not to that's how you
take back control of your decisions and
your life so i recently
listened to this chinese song and i got
obsessed with it i got obsessed with it
i was playing all day long and i just i
loved i don't know what they're saying i
don't know which i don't know what the
words mean i just loved i loved it i
loved it i go to bed
and lyrics start coming to me rap lyrics
in full sentences right the first one
comes in okay wake up i'm in bed i'm
lying in bed i'm trying to sleep you
know it's eleven o'clock trying to sleep
faster idea rap lyric come okay i write
it down again rap leaders come write it
down
more more and more write it down until
three in the morning i haven't slept yet
ideas just keep coming for this song
that's like i need to make a wrap
and then what comes into my head is that
what you can make a wrap
it's easy to get locked in into i can't
mode i can't do this i can't start that
i can't do a rap i didn't go to school
for that
not that you go to school for rap you
know i didn't rap growing up i don't
have musical talent right that's not
what people know me for that's how
people expect for me i can't rap
that's where most people quit
but instead i decided i was gonna get up
at three something in the morning go to
my computer finish writing out my lyrics
and then i spent the day rapping
and that night finished the video sent
it off to uh christina my editor to put
it together and the next day would
release my rap video now maybe you love
it maybe you hate it it's gotten some
decent responses it was tons of fun to
put together and most importantly
i taught myself and all of these things
these are all great micro moments to
teach yourself that you're amazing
whenever you say i can't
and you do it
that's how you build self-confidence
that's that's the birthplace of
self-confidence self-love self-respect
is taking something that you think that
you can't do and just trying
not even doing it full out because i
don't expect my rap to go off and win
any kind of awards right but i tried it
i did it i released it
expect a second beginning that's okay
it's normal it's part of the process but
in those moments of i can't and then
turning them into something that
actually exists
is where your genius will come
i look at my top 10 series and it's
partly why i have kanye on my wall
because the first video that i made was
on kanye first top 10 was on kanye was
five years into my youtube career
i did a response to my friend mark
drager
from phantom media and
i said initially i can't do this
like i can't make a video now on this i
have all these other commitments i have
a full day ahead of other stuff that i'm
supposed to do and said no
i did actually i'm just gonna do it
forget it i'm gonna make it and i didn't
expect it to do well
luckily it actually did and then that
became this whole thing of making i
don't know how many
top tens
hundreds maybe a thousand i don't know
how many top ten how many times have i
done i have no idea
but it started off as just idea
trust your ideas
know that they're amazing
stop saying i can't to yourself
this is where you need to take control
of your head in your heart you have to
make decisions with your heart
and then use your head to figure out how
to do it anytime you're doing something
new super important anytime you're doing
something new i'm making it i'm going to
make a wrap i'm going to make a top 10
video i'm going to do anything outside
my normal thing right same for you
anytime you're doing something new
it doesn't make sense
because it's new
what is brand new doesn't make sense
you're creating something new and so
your head your logical brain that's
designed to keep you safe doesn't
understand it its job is to to protect
you and says don't do that
you can't do that
because one has ever been done and
because we have all these reasons why
it's not possible for you not just
anybody else for you you can't do it
because you haven't done it before
that's what your head says
your heart can create something new your
heart creates art your heart makes up a
world that hasn't existed before
and so at the very beginning of many
projects your head and your heart are
against each other your heart's saying i
want to make this your head say you
can't make this
and so you end up staying stuck in limbo
with all these ideas never taking
momentum because your your head and your
heart are fighting you've got your foot
on the gas and the break at the same
time never moving knowing that you're
capable of more and so you make the big
decisions in your life with your heart
and then you rally your head to say okay
we're doing this i'm making the rap
video i'm making the top ten you're
gonna do your crazy idea and then your
head says
okay they're serious
let's figure out how not to die doing
this right let's figure out how to
actually make it work
so you make the big decisions in life
with the heart and then you use your
head to figure out how to go out and
accomplish it if you change how you feel
about something you change how you act
the problem is most of the time we don't
catch our feelings if you're feeling
negative angry frustrated depressed it
doesn't matter what the thing is that
you're trying to accomplish you're not
going to give it your all and you're not
going to get results because of your
negative emotional state if you don't
start changing how you feel you're never
going to make progress on the goals that
you set for yourself so one of the
things i love doing whenever faced in a
negative situation is say it's the best
it's the best i'm wearing this hat says
fanta because friend of the channel mark
jager pointed out to me when i was
saying it's the best that i'm a reframer
i'm reframing i never heard of the
concept before reframing means you take
this negative situation and then you
spin it you reframe it so that it's
positive so that it motivates you so
that's exciting so that it pushes you
forward instead of it being a negative
thing that is all-encompassing and
depressing and brings you down and he
said well you're always positive because
you're just a reframer
and it he has his anagram and i'm a
number six or something i don't know he
can give you more details you want to
know what number you are and what it
means go follow mark.dragon on instagram
and ask him but
i don't think that's something that's
just in me i think everybody can learn
how to do it everybody can learn how to
reframe you take whatever negative
situation that's in front of you and say
this is the best
right now this is the best where this
came from was i was on a airplane from
vancouver to los angeles and that's a
five-hour flight give or take and i had
to sit next to this really smelly dude
and there was no other option i had to
stay on the plane i had to make my
flight i had to speak at this event the
only other option was get off the plane
and he was really smelly i'm sure he
didn't want to be smelly and sure that
wasn't his you know intention or
ambition it just happened probably had
three stopovers you know hadn't showered
in in however long and just he's stuck
and in my head i'm trying to find
solutions there's no solutions and so
i'm upset i'm complaining you know
there's 15 seconds of back unfortunately
this sucks i can't believe it and then
here's what happens in my head i say
this is the best this negative thing
that's in front of me right now this is
the best
this is my chance to show myself
what i'm made of right and so he's
sitting right here next to me i'll look
over
and just breathe it in
breathe that in breathe in that smell
breathe it in
to show myself
that this is not the limit
that this one dude is not going to ruin
my day and i feel great now about myself
because self-confidence comes from doing
difficult things and i just did
something difficult and that's where
it's the best came from it was a it was
a quick trigger to myself to say this is
the best it's the best and now it's
become this thing that any time i'm
facing a really negative situation that
feels overwhelming and possible just
want to complain find somebody to blame
and say it's your fault now this is the
best this is my chance to show myself
and the world what i am made of and so
you can flip it for yourself
what is so overwhelming so impossible so
crazy that is bringing you down you look
at your calendar you look at your list
of emails and it's just depressing great
this is the best if you believe like i
believe that your purpose comes from
your pain if you believe that the thing
that you struggled with the most in life
becomes your calling for the rest of
your life the time that you struggled
and suffered the most as a human your
your purpose for the rest of your life
is to help other people who currently
are who you used to be
then that thing that happened that that
massively negative thing the most
painful moment in your life actually is
the best
because it's gonna allow you to serve
hundreds thousands maybe millions of
people through your purpose so that
negative things in front of you tell
yourself it's the best most people have
not taken control of their schedules you
wake up like an accident start
responding to other people's emergencies
and help other people build their dreams
instead of you building yours
it's time for a change you deserve
better and this video is going to show
you how i think one of the biggest
reasons why so many entrepreneurs don't
take enough action is because when you
get motivated you don't do enough you
feel the motivation you feel the
boldness feel the confidence but you're
not taking enough action you're not
doing enough i remember going to my
first tony robbins event this is before
uh i knew tony one on one before i did
the interview with him on my channel
i just went to see what would the event
be like i've i've seen so many different
videos of so many different people and i
felt like you know what for most people
going to their event it'd probably be
the same as just watching on youtube but
for tony i felt you know what i think
his event might be different there's
something that tells me by going to his
event it'll be different than what i
just see on youtube through the content
and so i went and i went with my wife i
went with three people on my team i paid
for everyone to go out and went to our
first tony robbins event
and at the end of the last day if you've
never been to tony robbins event it's on
fire you're you're motivated you're
jumping you're dancing you're hugging
you're high-fiving you're you're
breaking through limits it's it's
amazing and by the end of the last day
you see everybody in the streets you're
pouring out everybody's all pumped up
and energized i'm i'm gonna do this i'm
gonna do that
i remember one of the people that i
brought with me he's like yeah i'm gonna
do all this stuff and he's like yelling
and so fired up and excited he's like
well what are you doing evan like i'm
looking at my calendar
because
this is why so many people fall off you
go to an event like that and then you
fall off because you're not making it
consistent success is habits so whenever
you decide to make a change you have to
at least for me i look immediately to my
calendar
so if my goal is now i want to be a big
youtuber great when am i going to make
videos it's got to be in the calendar if
something in the calendar is never going
to happen and so anytime you want to
make a meaningful change you have to
default to thinking what am i going to
put into my calendar because success is
habits and so it's great to be motivated
maybe these videos do it for you maybe
events maybe books podcasts awesome
you're getting it from somewhere you
feel motivated great
show me in your calendar where you are
spending the time to actually make the
thing happen otherwise
you're just living off some fumes you
know you get motivated for a day or two
feels amazing and then you fall back
down to normal if you want that dream
life you want that next step for
yourself it's got to come from changing
your habits changing what's in your
calendar to make sure that what you say
you want out of life you're actually
working towards making that happen if
you want to become a millionaire or
influence a million people you need to
learn to build trust this is where you
can really win as an entrepreneur
because people have a really hard time
trusting big companies to do the right
thing so this is where you win
you win by not trying to be exactly like
the big companies you win by showing
that you actually care and will do the
right thing by the customer so bringing
it to a youtube world as an example
i think everybody should be responding
to all comments
one of the things that i believe in is
every comment we try to get a response
to every comment gets a response every
comment gets a response and at the
beginning when you're doing a youtube
channel
it's easy
my first video on youtube
it took me a year to get three comments
i made a video within one year there
were only three comments on that video
the first comment was my mom thank you
mom the second comment was my older
sister thank you alexandra and the third
comment was from some random dude a new
star somebody discovered my channel
right
one year three comments those are pretty
easy to respond to right
it's super easy in the early days when
you're not getting comments if you're
getting a comment a day a comment a week
couple comments a day it's easy to
respond to what happens when people
scale is they stop responding to
comments because they don't know how to
scale the business because
at the beginning they're doing
everything themselves and it doesn't
take up a lot of time but as you start
getting more comments it starts to take
up more time
i get hundreds of comments every day on
my on my youtube channel i
can't respond to every single comment
personally myself
if i could i could if i did it then i
wouldn't do anything else i'm going to
be making this video because i was
spending all my time responding to
people's comments right that's the
process
but just like any other business when
you start a business you're doing
everything yourself if you start selling
flowers on the street you're doing
everything right you've got to find the
flowers you've got to sell the flowers
you've got to distribute your flowers
you're doing everything
as you grow and as you get a flower
store
then you bring on a team right and you
have people who are selling flowers for
you and opening this door for you and
cleaning the store for you you're still
doing work
right you're doing more important work
you can't do all of the tasks in the
business at all times if you're always
doing everything you're never going to
scale
and so i believe that bigger youtube
channels should hire a team to respond
to comments i have an awesome guy my
team named velko who you'll see
responding to a lot of comments and
he'll save the comments that i need to
see so if there's feedback or
suggestions or improvements i want to
see them if there's criticism i want to
see it if it's just saying thank you
open for the video amazing i feel the
love i don't need to see all of those
comments that come in right i'll i'll
sort through some of them respond to
some of them but that's not going to be
the best use of my time every day
because then i'm not making videos and
so make that equivalent for yourself
at the beginning it's easy to show hard
and easy to show care because you don't
have that many customers because maybe
you only have one customer and so you
can show them the love but as you scale
and grow how can you continue to do that
whether it's you doing that most
important element yourself because
that's the thing that drives it or you
have people on your team that really
show that love and support because you
want to make sure the customer feels
respected and appreciated it's really
easy to build trust in a one-on-one
situation it's harder as you build and
scale your clients and so you need to
build and skill your culture alongside
hard work is your ticket in no matter
where you come from what you look like
what your skills are hard work is always
the ticket in the odds might be against
you awesome now what quit on your dreams
or keep working hard how you answer that
question will change your life so i have
an agent in new york and when i first
started the agency i almost didn't get
in
i didn't get in because i'm a weird case
for them my agent now he looked at me
back then and this must have been six or
seven years ago by now and he said evan
i love your message the problem is
you're not a very good communicator
and that hurt at the beginning because i
had already done some speaking gigs i'd
already been making videos for three or
four years you know i've had hundreds if
not a thousand videos already under my
belt and here he is saying that i suck
at communicating and he said the people
that he typically works with are people
who are already in media who have tons
of experience who are great in front of
the camera they need help refining their
message
he said for you i love your message
you've got a great message you just suck
at being a little communicated
wow
and so okay great well where do we go
from here and he said i'm going to take
a flyer on you
i don't normally do this
i'm going to take a flyer on you and see
where you go
and i didn't want to waste my
opportunity i didn't even know that you
could get an agent as a as a business
person as an entrepreneur as a speaker i
mean i guess i heard a speaking houses
but an agent i thought more
entertainment or sports not for business
so i didn't want to lose this
opportunity you know i didn't want to
regret not giving it my best and so i
said okay great tell me what i need to
do i'm the worst right now
awesome i i don't have the skills that
everybody else here has
how can i get better what do i need to
do tell me and he said okay so your
first challenge is i need you to make a
bio video i need you to tell your story
a foundation story video
make it 20 to 40 minutes long
and
record it and i'm going to look at it
and i'm going to give you my feedback on
it okay great so i recorded it the next
day
and it was in the morning i recorded it
sent it to him he gave me feedback
and then at lunch i recorded it again he
gave me feedback i recorded it again in
the evening
and i did it 30 to 40 times
there's a lot
over over the course of however many
days you know 10 to 12 days i guess uh i
recorded the video over and over and
over and over and over and over and over
again every time i give me feedback i do
it again feedback do it again
and i got better
and i got better and over the course of
a couple
months when i was making three videos a
day practicing sucking but just
practicing and trying to get better and
listening feedback and trying to improve
i quickly became the best case at the
agency i quickly became the number one
person from from views from subscribers
from best practices i copy what evan's
doing now i'm being brought on to help
them with their clients and train some
of them on how they can get better on
youtube and build their brand
from being the worst from the guy who
almost didn't get in
because the people who were joining them
one maybe had bigger egos but also
were having a hard time finding the time
to make a video a week
and if they're not making a video a week
or having a hard time doing it and i'm
making three a day even if i suck i'm
gonna get better i'm gonna outpace just
because i'm willing to work just because
i'm putting in the effort you might not
have the skills you might not have the
talent you might not have the looks you
might not have what you think you need
to have
how does an introvert
build a huge audience and and spread a
huge message and be famous on youtube i
don't know i mean i'm working on it join
me on my journey
we'll figure it out together
that was my agent's concern when i first
got started and i'm i'm breaking the
mold and doing things in a way that
haven't been done and you can do the
same thing
through hard work hard work doesn't
guarantee your success there's a lot of
people who work really hard and never
win a lot of people who work 12-hour
days and are doing minimum wage jobs
they're working hard and they don't win
you have to work hard and you have to
work smart but it's not one or the other
the people who were in the agency were
working smart but we're making one video
a week
i was working less smart
but making three videos a day so i'm
gonna get better i'm gonna get smarter
i'm gonna make it faster i'm gonna i'm
gonna show you what i can do
hard work is always your ticket in and
one of the biggest problems is people
just aren't working either hard enough
or smart enough
you just want it too soon and you can be
impatient and it's amazing but better
than being impatient with the results is
being impatient with yourself
most people are impatient with the
results like it's not coming fast enough
like where are my subscribers or my
views it's not happening my first video
took me a year to get three comments and
the first one was my mom the second
sister and the third was some random
dude right a year to get three comments
and two of the people are in my family
you're impatient with the results what
you should be is impatient with yourself
when you're not getting results when
it's not happening
audit yourself are you putting in the
work are you doing enough work are you
working smart enough are you applying
the right strategies get more frustrated
with yourself and your effort more than
that the results aren't there because if
you woke up every day and did that
equivalent of making three videos a day
when other people are making one video a
week you will eventually win
it might be slower than you'd like but
it's always slower than you like but you
will eventually win because hard work is
always your ticket in you will never
lose in life if you have valuable skills
you won't lose your house you won't lose
your car you won't lose your clients if
you have a skill that brings people
value the economy can collapse the
algorithms can change but as long as you
have a skill that solves problems for
people you will be safe so i'm seeing
this a lot in the youtube world now i
have a new course out helping people get
to a million subscribers on youtube we
can link up the description there if you
want in and people are saying well
should i
still do youtube is it too late like
youtube won't be here in five years or
ten years or maybe it's gonna be the
next thing that should hop on it's not
about the platform like right now it's
winning the platform that is currently
winning
you need to crush it right like youtube
should be your home if you're trying to
make an impact you're trying to be a
thought leader you have a message to
spread youtube has to be your number one
place it just has to be right now
otherwise you're not making a smart
decision but whether youtube is still
around in 20 years five years doesn't
matter because the skill set that you
learn you can take anywhere the ability
to communicate you could take to any
platform you could take to the next
thing i don't anticipate youtube still
being around in 20 years but my ability
to make videos talking to a lens
that's not gonna go away that can serve
me for life right whether that's vr evan
or hologram evan you know coming into
your living room that's that's going to
be me it's going to be amazing i'm
pumped i look forward to it
any algorithm change that people are
freaking out about anybody who's
complaining about the economy going down
or the algorithm changing you've already
lost that's a losing mindset
when i was first starting my youtube
channel
i always saw the algorithm as a chance
to win right
you should see if you're a small creator
on any platform youtube instagram
anything and the algorithm shifts that's
your greatest advantage you should be
cheering you should want more algorithm
changes if you look at a traditional
established boring market uh it's hard
to win
real estate could be hard to win right
financial markets can be hard to win
it's not that it's not possible it's
just hard to win because there's a lot
of people who have who have decades of
experience and no more than you and it's
hard to close that gap of experience
with social media with youtube every
time there's a big algorithm change the
people who are experts at the last thing
they're crying instead of adjusting
that's how you win that's how you get
ahead of them that's how you become the
top dog is because you're gonna go learn
the new algorithm when everybody is
wishing and hoping that the old
algorithm comes back and this happens
for every platform it happened for
facebook every time they changed your
algorithm or updated the the feed and
what was shown there people always freak
out and complain and they signed they
want petitions and like let's go back to
what it used to be
don't sign those petitions don't jump on
that bank when that is loser thinking
never ever ever ever ever ever ever do
that it's loser thinking and that's how
most people think
that's a mindset shift that i want to
make for the collective but more
importantly for you
that whenever there's a big change
embrace it go all in on it learn it
that's how you're going to leapfrog
everybody else so the faster the rate of
change the more you should be cheering i
still get pumped for an algorithm change
me i mean now i'm at now i'm closer to
the top right i mean i don't know what
the top is i got 2 million subscribers
and 300 million views and all these
channels
i still love it anytime an algorithm
change comes out i'm still pumped train
yourself like a change is coming i'm
pumped get excited because there's still
people who are ahead of me or even the
people below me that i'm competing with
for for attention and for space
if they're sitting there complaining
about how it's changed and they're
dropping in their views awesome i'll
pick up those views because i'm going to
learn what the new algorithm is all
about
same thing with the economy when the
economy crashes everybody who's
complaining about how it used to be
they're not going to win it's comforting
to join a club and wish things to be how
they used to be but we're not going back
to that
so the faster you realize that and make
improvements the faster you can learn
and actually build a great business some
of the greatest businesses in the world
were built in recession in depression
that could be you if you decide to be
let's hop back to skills for a second i
look at jake paul logan paul they
started on vine right
vine was was their claim to fame they
had tons of success in making these
super short videos
vine gets shut down
right boom gone this is don't put all
your eggs in one basket i think that's
loser thinking too
it's loser thinking
they went all in on vine and and then
vine got shut down oh no what did they
do they moved to youtube instead of
crushing it millions of subscribers look
at their growth on youtube over the past
i don't know two years three years blew
up why
they didn't just come out of nowhere
they had the skill set they had the
skill set that they learned from doing
the thing right the skill set to make a
good video they then brought to a new
platform if youtube goes away
you're learning the skill set of how to
communicate how to make great videos
that whatever comes next
people are freaking out about the ftc
coming in and cop on youtube okay so if
kids aren't
able to get content on youtube where
they're gonna go go be there
instead of trying to fight
what is already happening
go be at the place where the kids are
gonna be
embrace the change
that's where you that's where you can
win when everybody else is fighting and
angry and screaming and yelling and
complaining and wishing it used to be or
quitting the platform and getting upset
go be where they're gonna be it's it's
easy it's a simple win
most people don't have that mindset it's
why most people lose my most businesses
can't evolve most most businesses shut
down it's people very rarely transition
from one platform to another from one
business to another even though they
have the skill sets and capabilities to
do so because they don't have the
mindset to do so
people who crushed myspace very few of
them are still around
on different platforms looking at look
at hollywood the rock is doing it will
smith is doing it moving from hollywood
films to youtube where's brad pitt
where's george clooney like they're in a
dying industry
they should be embracing youtube they
don't want to they have the skills they
have the skills it's transferable you
don't think george clinton could come in
and crush youtube if you wanted to
of course he could calling you out
george clooney let's go make it happen
right it's just about picking up the
skill set that will keep you safe in any
environment but it's also having a
mindset to follow through and try the
new things instead of complaining about
the changes that are currently happening
the easiest way to win is to do work
that you love making a new video is easy
for me i've done 6 000 plus videos i
still love them i still enjoy it but
there is a chandelier sitting in the
trunk of my car right now that i have no
interest in installing i have i have no
idea how to install a light i have no
interest in learning how to install a
light and so i've asked my friend mark
drager from fanta to come and help
install the light for me if you're doing
a business that you don't know and that
you don't love and you think it's just
gonna be easy money
news flash it's never just easy money
you're going to lose you have to go
through what i call the blinders test
now blinders are things that people put
on horses so there's those black patches
that they put here on the side of the
horse so the horse doesn't get
distracted so the horse isn't like going
all over like this all they can see is
what's in front of them and it forces
them to just focus and go in front of
them now side note apparently they
actually have this for humans too and
some tech companies are using them where
they have blinders for humans that seems
a little crazy to me but listen if
blinders help you focus then by all
means go for it but you need to pass the
blinders test so what is the blinders
test for me it's those moments in time
where you have absolute clarity for what
you need to do where you know where you
want to go where you have direction and
purpose and this is the window that you
need to jump through for me right now
it's youtube
yes i've been on the platform for over
10 years but this is a special moment in
time for youtube right now for evan
carmichael plus youtube right now i'm
hitting it on strides we've got i don't
know how many channels right now a lot
too many maybe but i want to have 100
channels this is a moment in time
youtube's not going to be around forever
and it's going to morph and it's going
to become something else and i'm going
to have different interests at some
point this is the moment of time that
you need to then push hard i see
opportunities as windows there's this
window that's in front of you right now
and the window's open but it's not going
to be open forever
at some point that window of opportunity
is going to shut
and that's when people look back and say
i had
i could have done it and and that other
person they made so much money off of my
idea it wasn't your idea they did it the
only difference between you and the
people who are winning is they started
they did it they take action every
single day there's no reason why that
person can't be you you have to jump
through the window with full force and
put your blinders on and stop thinking
about everything else that's around you
that's if you have absolute clarity and
direction
now there will be other moments in your
life and i think i think life moves like
this i think you'll have moments in life
where you have absolute clarity and
purpose and direction and it'll be other
moments where you're not so sure what to
do
and then you have to open up the funnel
again sticking to
the blinders when you don't know what
you're doing is not a great strategy
this this happens to a lot of
entrepreneurs where they have focus for
their business but then they lose
interest in their business and then they
bought themselves a job and they're too
afraid to get out of that business
because of what it means because of the
opportunity cost because of everything
that they've they've sunk into the
business
because people might say well what a
failure if they close now and they
should have been out of their business
three years ago but they're still going
don't let that be you you're never going
to win doing work that you hate
if you don't like your business anymore
you need to adjust it or you need to
move on dump it move on to something
else if i stop liking videos
i will just decide no more videos
happening sorry guys
maybe sell it to somebody else or just
stop
because i'm not going to win doing work
that i hate either and so if you feel
your foot kind of pulling out of the
water while you still have some interest
move on to the next thing and so when
you know what you want to do you're
focused hyper focused that's all you're
doing when you don't know what you want
to do you open up the scope
and that's okay and i think everybody
will go through these phases in life
you will have absolute clarity and so
you need to go off and do instead of
finding all the reasons why you can't do
and when you don't know what you want to
do don't stress out and worry that you
don't know what you want to do try a
bunch of stuff say yes to everything pay
attention to the feeling the most
important thing when you're trying
something new is do you love the process
of it
not is this going to be your next big
opportunity did you love the process
even though you sucked doing it i sucked
making my first video i love the process
i sucked when i first learned salsa
dancing i love the process you're
supposed to suck at the start that's
okay
you don't need to get instant results
if you love the process you will win if
you got instant results but you don't
love it you're never gonna win it's just
never gonna happen you're not gonna win
and so depending where you are on this
spectrum of absolute clarity to having
no idea
dictates what your actions should be
when you know what you need to do stop
making excuses stop having justification
and just go off and do the damn thing
and if you don't know what you want to
do then explore
stop feeling sorry for yourself stop
complaining it's okay explore you will
find the thing that then you can focus
on until the next time you expand it a
good question ask yourself is do you
actually love this do you want it badly
enough i love making videos i sucked at
the beginning i'm still working to get
better i've gotten better over the you
know decade i've been on youtube i still
look forward to it i still love it i
still work every week creating content
for you guys we're putting out six
videos a day across the different
channels now it's it's wild it's crazy
and i still love it we're putting in the
work i'm putting in the work my team's
putting in the work because we still
actually love the process of doing it so
so many entrepreneurs quit and give up
because you'll say you'll do whatever it
takes but you're not going to if you
don't actually love the process you
don't actually love the work you will
not do whatever it takes you will only
force yourself to do something that you
hate for so long until you give up and
quit so big reason why entrepreneurs
don't put in enough work because you
just don't love it enough when you
understand what your single most
important core value is everything else
becomes so much easier so for me it's
belief right believe is my single most
important core value how does that help
well with every decision that i make
it's seen through the lens of belief
every video content that i make is about
belief it has to be every interaction i
have every workshop every book every
meeting all of it has to be run through
the believe
framework right the glasses of belief if
i'm hiring somebody onto my team skills
alone aren't enough it's great that you
can write copies do you believe in
entrepreneurs it's a big difference so
when you understand your core value
everything else becomes clearer and
you're less likely to follow what other
people want you to do everybody around
you they have a goal for you even if
it's well intentioned they have opinions
on what you should do with your life
everybody around you this is what you
should do with your life everybody has
an opinion you don't know which way to
go if you don't know which way to go
it's because you don't know what you
stand for because you're standing on
quicksand but when you understand your
one word your who your most important
core value it's like you're standing on
a rock that nobody can push you from so
how do you figure that out quickly right
i mean this is
200 something pages
let's boil it down super quick for you
you want to think about all the people
that you love
your favorite teacher what you loved
about your parents think about your
favorite musician your favorite band
your favorite song your favorite movie
your favorite book all your favorite
things i think that when you are around
consuming it reading and being with them
it makes you feel bold alive amazing
confident unstoppable right we've all
had those moments it's just not
consistent enough yet we're gonna make
it for you it's just not consistent
enough yet and so write down a list of
five to ten things that make you come
alive again people your favorite teacher
movies all of those things that make you
that you love that you love like you
could get lost spending time with them
or reading them or listening to them
then write down three key words that
describe each of them
so your favorite teacher why did you
love
mr jones it's not because he taught you
grade four math right there's something
else about mr jones that you love
why do i love seabiscuit the movie
because it's about an oversized jockey
and an undersized horse and an owner
that has no money and all of these
things they all come together it's
believe right my parents
taught me that i'm evan cause really
carmichael i can do anything that i
believe that i can right and so through
all the things that i love believe is
the common thread what is it for you you
have to figure it out you have to figure
it out it doesn't have to take you years
of work just write down all of the
people and the things that you love
three key words for each like do this
this is important
just do it today it'll make a huge
difference in your life it's worth it
this is the best 15 minutes you can
spend in your life do it
pause the video and do it and then just
see what comes up consistently what word
comes up over and over and over and over
and over and over again chances are
that's your one word that's your who
then when you discover it you have to
start living that life the reason most
people don't win isn't because you don't
have great ideas you're a genius the
only thing missing is momentum you're
dreaming huge that's amazing i love it
but there is zero momentum it's never
going to be the right time and nobody is
coming to save you the time is now to
make your dreams happen so here's a
really fun example yesterday i needed to
take a break from my work to go to the
bathroom so i go to the bathroom open up
my feedly and start looking at you know
some of the new stories that were
happening and there was this amazing
video that i saw about a busker in
toronto who
uh a company organized what they called
a cash mob instead of a flash mob they
would all show up at this guy doing his
you know guitar uh singing playing and
just throw money at him not at him but
in the guitar case right and they were
they probably made like a thousand bucks
they were throwing 20s and 50s not just
pennies and you know dollar bills and
stuff but give him tons of money and and
and he's starting to get overwhelmed
he's playing the guitar he's getting
overwhelmed and and i'm i'm getting
motivated and excited and just heartfelt
what a great moment and i decide in that
moment we need to make this video more
public we need to spread it this has to
go up on the channel i need to spread
awareness i want to i want to promote
this company who put this together i
love it what a great idea
and so right away like here's the thing
you get a great idea trust your great
ideas go do something about it i could
have easily filed that away
next week i'll work on it and then what
guess what's going to happen next week
i'm not going to work on it because i'm
going to move on to something else right
i'm in the middle of my day i've got
priorities and plan for that day
and then this thing pops up
i trust that idea trust that it's great
and that i got to do something about it
because if i'm inspired if you're
inspired you're going to create gold
you're going to create magic
if you're not inspired then just keep
doing the work that you're doing
hopefully it's not depressing and
negative it's just you're creating it's
amazing you're in your flow but when
something new comes up that you're super
excited about i think you need to follow
that through and so i i parked a little
chunk of my day yesterday to then make
that video and i made the ending and i
made the thumbnail and i made the
description and i made the title and i
created it all in one shot and i sent it
off to my editor christina we love you
christina say hey we got to put this up
on the channel find the time this is not
scheduled in my usual content calendar
but let's find a time put it up right
and that maybe took i don't know half an
hour
it took half an hour out of my day that
i was supposed to do other stuff to make
that happen because momentum matters
momentum matters it's the most important
thing you're a genius the ideas you have
are gold they're genius you're just not
doing enough with it success is the
progressive realization of a worthy
ideal what i took away most from that
definition is the word progressive you
want progress you want to learn you want
to keep growing what was once a
challenge for you is now simple and it's
very easy to fall into a routine that
once served you but is now limiting you
the day you stop progressing is the day
that you start to hate your life and it
can be sneaky it can sneak up on you
without you even noticing what happened
so i was trying to think of a personal
story to share with you about this and i
realized it's been more than 10 years
since i've actually felt that i felt
that i've stopped progressing
that that i started to hate what i was
doing it's been over 10 years it was it
was basically since i started on youtube
and i'm going to share with you that the
the hacks that i used so that you won't
fall into that rut but what happened for
me 10 years ago was i built my website
right i sold my business i had success i
was speaking around the world i started
building my website
and i built it into a giant platform we
had a hundred thousand plus pages of
content making money from advertising
and i just stopped liking the business
it started to feel like we're putting
out content we're putting out articles
just trying to make money putting out
articles that that
um i didn't always believe 100 in we had
a bunch of guest people writing content
right we had four or 5 000 authors for
the website and not all of their
opinions or views or mindset or voice
reflected my own
and i just stopped liking the business
it was a successful business making
money building a team i had eight people
i think at that time and i decided you
know what i this isn't
this isn't i'm losing the love for this
i need to try new things
and i started making youtube videos it
was one experiment i probably did a
bunch of different things but youtube
was one experiment that i sucked at but
i loved and i kept coming back to and
and it taught me it taught me a lesson
it taught me that you need to explore
this this is what i tell a lot of people
when they're entrepreneurs i had a woman
uh melissa who joined me on an ig live
the other day and she's talking about
how she's got a real estate business
that's making her money but she wants to
be a speaker and the speaking business
is growing it can't support her fully
yet but the real estate business gives
her a lot of money she said well i like
doing both
like well no you
don't right like in five years where do
you want to be you want to still be
doing real estate no no five years i
don't want to be doing that i want to be
doing the speaking thing okay great
that's where you need to start spending
more of your time it doesn't mean quit
the job it doesn't mean stop doing real
estate or stop doing the thing that
you're just okay with but while you
still have one foot in it you have to
explore you have to try you have to
taste you got to see what else you can
do spend one day a week two days a week
depending on your financial situation is
my advice to her spend one day or two
days a week focusing on the speaking
business so that in six months you could
be out of the real estate business and
being speaking full-time
and then do anything that you love
right if you just like it
that should be a warning sign to get out
not asap but you need to start exploring
but so many people end up hating the
things they're doing so many
entrepreneurs start a business they love
it it's challenging it's exciting it's
exhilarating and then they found that
they bought themselves a job and they
actually hate their business and then it
becomes too late to get out because you
can't find the person to sell it to or
you just have to walk away from it
but so many people just like it and
you're not exploring enough to chase
down the opportunity you don't win a
nobel prize by telling yourself that you
want to win a nobel prize you win a
nobel prize by having a mission so big
that it forces you to become somebody
new a stronger more bold more resilient
version of you if you make success your
goal you will most likely miss it
because you have the wrong outcome in
mind make impact your goal make your
mission your goal and you'll end up
having more success than you ever
thought possible i look at my youtube
channel as an example and
the next goal would be to have 10
million subscribers right i got my 100
000 plaque i got three of them there i
got my million plaque
the next goal is 10 million and there's
nothing wrong with having goals but the
problem is if i made 10 million the
thing
like all i'm doing is chasing down 10
million subscribers
it forces you to do short term decisions
that end up not serving you right if i
wanted to just blow up my channel the
best way to do it isn't actually to
spread positive content
negativity spreads much faster than
positivity if i made a top 10 video on
why this person sucked or an espresso
about how this person is an idiot or
people fighting people can't help but
see that people that's why people stop
to see the car accident on the highway
right we don't reward the good drivers
you want to see the chaos you want to
see what caused the flame there's a
fight on the street corner you stop to
see what's going on right we're
attracted to the negativity more than
the positivity that's a faster way to
blow up my channel the problem is
i wouldn't feel good about it
i don't want to spread negativity i
don't want to spread conflict and chaos
i don't want to spread pessimism i don't
want to spread
despair i don't want to spread ego i
don't want to spend negativity i just i
don't want to do that and so it would
lead to me flaming out before i ever hit
the goal
that's the problem you can have this
goal this is what most people do you
have some goal here's my goal i'm going
to do whatever it takes to get to that
goal the problem is you won't do
whatever it takes because it's going to
get too hard you can only do things for
so long that you don't love before you
quit and give up and so there's nothing
wrong with having a goal but more
important than the goal is the mission i
want to sell the world's biggest problem
it's something that's never going to
happen never in my lifetime it's never
going to happen i want people to believe
in themselves more it's never going to
hit that ultimate goal where everybody
is michael jordan at something it will
never happen and i wake up every day
trying to do that and so if you make a
goal
tied to some outcome like getting 10
million subscribers on youtube it's
gonna force you down a path that likely
won't serve you so you lead with the
mission you leave with the impact and
success will fall the difference in
people is their standards the world is
full of people who started with less
than what you already have right now and
they're winning and too many people are
out there complaining complaining that
you don't have the money that you don't
have the time that you don't have the
experience that you don't have the
personality for it all legitimate
logical reasons but
others have done it with those very same
circumstances as you with worse
circumstances than you the difference is
they have a higher standard for
themselves and today we're gonna raise
yours one of the things i'm most proud
about for myself why do i love evan
carmichael is because when i say i'm
gonna do something i do it especially
when it gets hard like it doesn't count
until it gets hard and i'm doing it not
just for other people i'm doing it and
that's because i promised you that i
would show up i'm doing it for myself
because i said i was going to do
something and then i go off and do it
this is the foundation of self-esteem a
self-confidence of self-love doing it
when you say you're gonna do it and so
on monday i usually have a two-hour
walk-in meeting with alex alex helps me
run trying to dance salsa he comes over
monday's my mentoring day and we'll
usually go for a two-hour walk around
the city and it's starting to get cold
you know it's winter time here it's
getting cold and so we bundle up and we
go for our two hour walk while we while
we talk and while we meet i'm trying to
do walking meetings more just for my own
health and and just because just for the
challenge of it because it's easy to
start something like that in the spring
or in the summer it's really hard to do
it when it's in the winter and you live
in toronto canada and it's snowing and
cold right so this monday alex was sick
he still came in he was sick he was
running a bit of a fever not crazy sick
but just sick
and nina my wife super karen said hey
maybe you shouldn't go for a walk
outside
and and in my heart just like come on no
we have to i said i was gonna do it
right i have to i have to for myself i
have to go on the walk like i'll go on
the walk and leave alex at my place and
and just film the meeting with him uh
but we came up with a different solution
which was i have a i live in a condo we
have a gym in my condo and we went down
to the condo gym and i walked on the
treadmill while he stood or sat next to
me for two hours because i said that i
was gonna do it
how important is that one two hour walk
not much right in itself not much am i
gonna get healthy from doing that one
walk no am i gonna lose weight by doing
that one walk no i'm gonna have so much
more mental clarity by doing that one
walk of course not
but it's the whole game because you're
teaching yourself that you follow
through you're teaching yourself that
you have high standards you're teaching
yourself that when you say you're going
to do something you follow through
because life is coming for you with a
ton of roadblocks
life is going to throw tons of curve
balls at you if you can only do the
thing that you said you were going to do
when it's easy and the path is perfectly
clear you're never gonna do it this is
why people don't stay consistent because
as soon as life gets hard
you let yourself off the hook
you allow your standards to drop to say
oh it's okay yeah of course i can't go
for a walk cause alex is sick
right and there are definitely
legitimate times when you should let
yourself off the hook if i was dying in
bed with the fever and i couldn't get
out of bed i wouldn't go for the walk
that makes sense don't be stupid there's
times when you need to be gentle on
yourself
but more often than not we are too
gentle on ourselves when we shouldn't be
i could have done the walk and we did it
we did it in the in the in the gym
downstairs and alex stood next to me and
sat next to me and didn't have to go
outside and and get the cold on him and
i still got my walk-in right and i feel
great about it
because i did it when it was hard
because here's this obstacle that life's
thrown at me here's an easy way when
everybody around me is saying you don't
have to go off and do it and a little
tiny voice inside my own head saying
okay well here's a chance you don't have
to do it like no be quiet voice i'm
doing it we're finding a solution let's
go
and the solution isn't gonna walk on the
treadmill downstairs what matters is
that you're productive that you get
results that you stop wasting time too
many people default to thinking that if
they just wake up an hour earlier
they're going to be way more productive
if you're not productive in a 16-hour
day what makes you think that you're
going to be more productive in a 17-hour
day when you have less sleep so this is
a
interesting message and timing for me
right now because
i i love beating the sun up i love it i
i love working
like it's my default state if nina is
off on a friday night with her friends
or something 80 chance i'm working i
love it i look forward to it when i go
close my eyes i can't wait for it to be
the next day like i'm pumped to go off
and do the work
i recently did a sleep study
and my doctor was concerned i wasn't
getting enough quality sleep so i went
to go do a sleep study and the doctor
after going through the results uh told
me that i need to be sleeping eight and
a half hours to nine hours a night
and it and it like
super disappointed me eight and a half
hours to nine hours are you kidding me
i'm trying to go from i was trying to go
from eight to seven i was waking up
after eight hours sleep and and feeling
still a little bit tired and so that's
why my doctor recommended even going to
the sleep study and i'm trying to figure
out how do i hack i take it down to
seven and still be fully functional not
not be you know
lazy and slow and not having my
cognition
and uh yeah he said i need to be
sleeping eight and a half to nine hours
a night he said is that is that normal
like are you not worried like no as long
as you're under 10 it's normal people
range from 6 to 10 and they're totally
fine like this sucks i mean i'm not
happy about it i'm still looking at how
can i hack my sleep more and we've tried
a lot i have the chili pad we've got you
know meditation before sleeping online
on the bed of nails with the thing
behind me the pillow the nail pillow uh
no
you know phones or computers x amount of
time before going to bed red light
filters on everything red lights no
lights at all in the place right like
just these real red lights going around
after sunrise after sunset
lots of it cool down the temperature i
don't know all of it don't eat past
eight o'clock no caffeine past two
o'clock all of it i'm doing all of that
stuff all of it right plus probably a
lot more stuff
i've i've studied and hacked away i
still believe there's a lot more hacking
i still want to get it from nine to
seven but but if i'm at nine and i need
nine i think you should get nine i'm at
the point now where if i wake up and the
sun is still
uh not up i stay in bed
and and that's actually
uh boosting of confidence it's like okay
so i wake up and sun hasn't come up yet
okay this is hard this is difficult it's
difficult for me to not get out of bed
i'm gonna stay in bed just because
now i'm i'm a i'm a weird duck
so maybe this works for you maybe it
doesn't but i was having a great
conversation with uh jeremy who's on my
team who
i've invested in his business he's
helping companies scale their youtube
channels and he was going through the
same thing where he was feeling a little
tired in the afternoon he wanted to nap
on some afternoons and that's never been
me so dude you need to just try
uh waking up without an alarm
and he normally he's up at 4 30 in the
morning or something um so just wake up
without an alarm and see how it goes and
he ended up sleeping for nine hours and
hating hating himself for doing it's
like dude maybe you need nine hours like
much more important than that extra hour
or two is what are you doing during the
day if if you're losing energy during
the day and you want to nap every
afternoon you're not being productive
like there's no way
sleep and be productive you need sleep
to win i think everybody should get a
sleep test i think it's a brutal
experience
you don't you barely sleep right when
you're there you got stuff up your nose
and a million sensors all over you but
to know how much sleep you actually need
and making sure that you're productive
during the time that you are awake
that's the most important thing that you
are productive during the time that you
are awake is way more important than if
you wake up before the sun gets up if
you are doing something new you are
going to get rejected if you're doing
something that you're not good at yet
you're going to get rejected if you're
doing something that goes against the
status quo
you are going to get rejected so you
have two choices live a life with zero
growth and never get rejected or chase
your dream
deal with the rejection that comes and
go change the world i have rejection all
the time in my life
from little rejections of making videos
that don't pop to bigger rejections of
projects that i care deeply about that
just don't fly and people don't accept
at the beginning i look i look at this
built to serve this is a great example
built to serve is my new book this book
i'm insanely proud of i think it's
life-changing i mean it should be i
think the work that you create should be
life-changing but i poured so much into
this and i think people need to read it
like i i desperately think that this
book will change a lot of people's lives
it could change your life i believe it's
not just hyperbole like i i truly
fundamentally believe it
when i came up with the idea
i was on my tour earlier this year and
i did not have time to write it right i
was on my tour i'm behind on everything
a million things being thrown at me
meeting people doing my events seeing
the cities and it just i just decided i
have to write this book because of all
the feedback i was getting from people
it was all the one-on-ones i was doing
with people the same questions kept
coming up how do i find my purpose how
do i know who i am how do i turn into a
business and so that's the that's the
point of the book figuring out what your
purpose is and how to use that to then
serve the world right it's called built
to serve
and make it into a business so you can
make money doing it and build a team and
go off and live your mission when i
first pitched my publisher on it they
didn't want it
they didn't want my book right so uh
your one word is down here that's with
penguin random house and penguin passed
so they had first my first deal with uh
penguin random house
typically how they'll do deals
especially with first-time authors is
you get you get a deal and then they
have the right of first refusal in your
next book
so as soon as i get my next book
they get the right to look at it first
before i give it to anybody else right
so that's why i signed so okay here we
go let's go it's a perfect fit
i mean it follows really nicely with
your one word
let's go right
and they said uh no we're gonna pass
like jah what how do you pa this is
better than your one word i mean i love
your one word it's great
but this is this is this is the whole
thing
how do you pass on this
um it's just
and we had to wait because it's 30 days
and all these anyway legal stuff um so
then we started looking at other
companies we started looking at other
publishing houses and there were other
ones that seemed to line up really well
with the content that they had the the
the author line up that they had
and
almost everybody everybody except the
last one right uh said no
and i mean like i got a i got a big
youtube channel we have momentum we
already have our first book we're like
why
and all sorts of different reasons you
know um just not not doing personal
development books anymore not whatever
uh nobody came out and said like we hate
you evan so maybe hopefully that's not
the reason
um
and then we found one that that picked
it up it's like okay
let's go and if if that one didn't pick
it up then then we would have kept
looking for more publishers or i would
have just made it myself just
self-publishing put it out
right
what do you do when the people around
you don't accept what you have when you
want to take something in a new
direction i could have done something
else i could have done something easier
if i just did a book about jack ma
right and his real success that would be
easier to pick up than this which i talk
about on the channel but it's not the
main thesis of the channel
but that's what i want to make and
that's what i'm going to make whether
it's i get a publisher or we're going to
you know create it myself it's going to
be birthed into existence because i
decided so and just taking that mindset
and approach you have to
if you love the thing if you're doing
something different
then you have to keep going when people
say that i don't want to pick it up that
it sucks that it's stupid that you're
maybe it's even a great idea but you're
not the person who's gonna do it
right you have to keep going i think
judging yourself is actually great i
think you need it i think it's healthy i
think people should be harder on
themselves the problem is people can't
handle being even a little bit harder on
themselves because they're already at
the point of being depressed or even
suicidal the secret starts with self
self-love your self-love has to equal
your self-criticism you have to be your
biggest fan as well as your biggest
critic the root problem isn't judging
yourself it's not loving yourself one of
the challenges to think of being human
is we are social animals we're social
creatures we rely on each other we need
each other we want to belong we want to
be part of tribes we want to do things
together right we want to be around
other people
so that makes us want to fit in and that
makes us
play small worry about what people think
about us because if we don't do the
thing that they want us to do they might
judge us and kick us out of the tribe
the good news is there's so many
different tribes you can do now right
there's so many different people that it
may not be your friends that you have
right now may not be your parents or
your family or your community right now
but whatever you want to do there is a
group of people who believe the same
things you believe you think the same
way you think and i think one of the
healthiest things that you can do is
whenever you feel the eyes of potential
judgment
for something that you want to do you
have to go off and do it just to show
yourself comparison to other people i
think is actually a good thing i think
you need it i think it helps you i think
it serves you the problem is most people
look at other people start feeling
insecure and then kick themselves down
the key
is to kick yourself forward
not down
but you need that kick otherwise you
stay where you are this is one of the
reasons why i love modern success why i
created all my youtube channels and all
the content that i've done and have the
people behind me on the wall because i
love looking at other people i love
learning from other people i love seeing
somebody do amazing things and say
that's what's possible
this is what's possible
i look at les brown as an example and i
think he's the greatest speaker of all
time at least that i've i've seen i
don't maybe maybe the ancient greeks
were better i don't know but but les
brown modern era on video i think is the
greatest speaker
and
i look at that and say that's what's
possible not that i can't do that here's
what most people do they look at les
brown and say well i can't do that
and then they start feeling insecure and
i'm just i'm just an impostor trying to
be like that now and then they quit
and then they feel they feel low
self-esteem when they and they beat
themselves up over because they're not
les brown
i look at les brown and say that's
what's possible this is what this is
what humans can actually accomplish and
achieve i want some of that i want to
get better i want to drive and improve
not to be the next les brown but he's
the best me but this is what's possible
i look at david goggins
man david goggins look he came out of
nowhere who was david goggins did you
guys know david goggins five years ago
no he blew up out of nowhere because of
the passion and intensity and truth of
his message right i love that and it's
easy to say and look at that say well
look at how passionate david goggins is
and look how he blew up i can never do
that
i'm not as strong as him i'm not as
crazy as him i don't have the same
mindset as him and so i can't do that
and you compare yourself to goggins and
then you say well i can't i can't and so
you don't start that's the problem
you should look at gawkins and say look
at what's possible you could come from
nowhere nobody knowing who you are and
in a short amount of time blow up
because you have a message that matters
you can look at how passionate he is
about his message every video he's got
insane passion right this guy he's not
going to give you
nice hugs and compliments but he he
cares about his message right you can
see that and you could take that as as
what's possible you can you can care
deeply about your message too and model
david goggins and and apply that to make
your message stronger and better i think
if you just were competing with yourself
i think you're actually going to suck
i think i think if you're the best at
something and you don't have any
competition i think you actually suck
being the big fish in a small pond
actually limits a lot of creativity uh
limits your ability to go off and crush
things i think i think it is i think
when you even even in animals when you
see animals going up against each other
in a race when when somebody's close you
work a little bit harder right i think i
think we need that in our ecosystem the
key though again is to make sure you're
kicking yourself forward to say this is
what is possible not this person's so
much better than me i suck feeling
insecure feeling depressed you need the
kick just make sure you're kicking
yourself forward not down it may not be
your fault but it's your responsibility
it's not your fault that you were born
broke but it's your responsibility to
fix it it's not your fault that you had
no education but it's your
responsibility to learn it it's not your
fault that you had no connections but
it's your responsibility to make them it
may not be your fault but it's your
responsibility and the sooner you accept
that the sooner you're gonna win so i
recently posted to my youtube community
tab a quote about momentum i think
people don't have momentum and i think
the path to get momentum is to do work
for free for ideal clients until you can
prove your value and then they pay you
so here's what i wrote i wrote if you
have no momentum no traction no clients
and start for free prove your worth and
build momentum give them something they
can't wait to have again and pay for
this time hashtag believe and every time
i write there's always tons of great
positive feedback but but this time
somebody wrote a
kind of negative comment and so i wanted
to read it because it's highly
applicable in this video he said kitsch
i don't know about some of your advice
everything is my fault and work for free
to which i reply yes when you embrace
those two you'll start questioning your
goals it's a hard message to to take on
right whether everything is your fault
everything is your responsibility where
you are right now it's not about beating
yourself up it's not about saying i suck
and i can't get out it's saying listen
this is what happened to me that's the
past the past doesn't have to equal to
the future everything that i was born
into and and the circumstances that i
grew up with they don't have to be where
i go going forward look at all your
heroes look at the people who've made
huge inroads change the world the people
that you look up to and aspire to be
like very few of them were born super
wealthy most of them had a worse
upbringing than you did and they could
make it so why can't you
you're just locked in your story too
many people are locked into their story
they're not taking responsibility you're
not saying this is my my problem to get
out of
i wasn't put here
right you've been drafted into a war
that you did not start you were put here
and you have to survive and then you
have to learn to thrive and it's that
decision
that you are in charge that you're
responsible that if you go to the mirror
and you say why am i not achieving my
goals why am i not further ahead
as long as you're blaming somebody else
that might keep you comfortable
it keeps you comfortable it means you
don't have to do anything right you're
not winning because your mom you know
hit you you're not winning because your
dad never supported you right you're not
winning because the school system sucks
as long as it's somebody else to blame
it's it's comforting
and everybody else around us are doing
the same thing nobody's taking
accountability everybody's saying it's
somebody else's fault right of course
it's not your fault that you're losing
because then you have to do something
about it and even if you're not losing
you're not hitting the goals as hard as
you should
and it's so much easier to put the blame
on somebody else and say well
it's that person's fault
well really it's the person in the
mirror it's you it's me i am not further
ahead
in my business on my youtube channel not
because of the youtube algorithm
not because my team didn't deliver the
right video on time me i'm the problem
it's my fault it's my responsibility
right i have to go fix it i created this
mess
it's not a mess is amazing but
i'm not at 10 million subscribers
because of me
it's not that people don't want to watch
the content and people don't want to be
inspired
it's me
i need to get better i need to improve
and and even if it wasn't my fault just
taking that on gives you hope that you
can change it as soon as you start
putting not even the blame i think blame
is not
i don't think blame helps i don't care
who's to put the blame i care how do we
fix it right if there's a problem that
happens in my business it's not like who
screwed up i don't care who screwed up i
care what are we gonna do to make sure
that we can get out of this hole and
then it doesn't happen again the next
time
right taking personal accountability for
where you're at
if you have not hit your goals
there's good news you can
but nobody's coming to save you
nothing's gonna magically change around
you you you're the change you will make
the change you can go make it happen
if i want to grow my business bigger i
need to accept that i need to grow
bigger me personally evan carmichael i
is my fault it's my responsibility i am
to blame
and use that as a kick forward to say
great like at the beginning that may
suck say oh man i've wasted how many
you know weeks months years going down
the wrong path just
casting
blame on other people realizing now it's
my fault okay what can you do about it
now you can change it like at the start
the reality the realization sucks but
then it's also the greatest thing of all
time if you're coming out of
from under the rock and realize oh my
god this is all my fault that gives you
the power to fix it because as long as
you're relying on somebody else to do
something and they don't show up you can
constantly blame them but you're never
growing you never accomplished anything
because you're waiting for them you have
to wait for anybody
it's just you
and you can fix it you have the strength
you have the power you're michael jordan
you have the abilities you have the
skill set and if you don't have it yet
you can develop it you can acquire it
because your heroes did it and you can
too the single greatest thing that you
can do to improve the quality of your
life is to take responsibility for it no
more blaming your parents or the country
or the government or your family or your
community or your education no more
blaming other people it's you
it's you it may not be your fault where
you are right now but it is your
responsibility alone to fix it you
didn't pick where you started but you
can choose where you end up
it's up to you so i remember growing up
my parents were very hardcore in
education you see my parents behind me
here
i'm eight or nine years of my parents
and we were middle class family we
weren't poor by any stretch but we also
you know we're not rich and my parents
invested
basically everything they had into our
education they put us all in the private
schools and taking three kids into
private schools was a giant chunk of the
income that they made and so we didn't
spend money on a lot of other stuff you
know i remember driving into my school
and all of my all of the friends all the
people at the school
had all these fancy cars that when
they're when they turn 16 they're you
know given a mercedes or bmw from their
family and you know my family had a
reliant cake card that kind of
made a bunch of noises that as i came
into to the school that was i don't know
how however many years old just because
my family you know prioritized
education and and we were playing in a
league that was
maybe above
our means but they valued that so much
and then we took a hit on other things
and i remember used to get made fun of
for the car
and i never went on the vacations that
they went on and i didn't have the fancy
watches and all that other stuff and
there was one friend of mine
who was kind of in a similar boat where
his parents
you know weren't making a lot of money
invested everything that they had into
his education too and so we quickly
became friends as the
uh as i guess the poor kids
at the school but it's funny now because
i never blame my parents i i'm super
grateful for the opportunities i mean
why i have them up on my wall that they
invested so much and that they cared and
it's on me like if my business doesn't
work out it's not their fault
right up until you know you can
potentially move out i don't know what
age you want to say if it's 14 15 16 18
but after a certain age you're an adult
i need to take responsibility for your
life the only thing missing in your life
is momentum you're a genius you've got
great ideas you are the michael jordan
of something the only thing that is
stopping you is your ability to do
difficult things and start building
momentum i think for so many people it's
not just doing the thing that scares you
first first thing in the morning it's
doing it at all most people just don't
do it at all you've got a great idea you
know it can work but you're afraid of
judgment you don't know where to start
you're afraid of it being not perfect
and people telling you that you suck and
you failing publicly you're afraid of
all that stuff and so you don't do
anything you got your foot on the gas
and break at the same time knowing that
you're capable of more knowing that you
have greatness in here but then being
too afraid to go off and execute it and
so i think not just starting your day
with the thing that scares you just
moving doing something anything just
getting started on your crazy idea it's
not that you're leaving it to the
afternoon it's that most people aren't
doing it at all so i was on a call with
an entrepreneur friend of mine yesterday
and she was upset she was frustrated she
had decided last year
mid last year right june july last year
that she needed to let somebody go on
her team this person was being toxic in
their environment was still producing
results for the company but just being a
big drag on the company on the culture
and on herself as trying to lead this
team of people and so she decided i
gotta let this person go
it's six seven months later now
and she still hasn't done it she still
hasn't done it because she's afraid of
maybe not finding the right person to
replace the impact of having to go
through training and hiring all over
again and she just hasn't made the
decision the biggest problem is she has
not decided and so i said
when is this gonna matter to you you
decided you decided right last year
six seven eight months ago and you still
haven't done the thing and she said well
if it gets to a year and i still haven't
done it then i have to go off and do it
and this is where your standards come
into place
how long after you've made a decision do
you actually start to do something about
it
in her case her standards were a year in
that she decided but then a year later
that's when that's when it's too much
that's when it's gone too far that if
she hasn't done it in a year now it's
too much i want you to shorten that gap
teach yourself that as soon as you
decide you do something you act you put
the plan into motion because you don't
have that many years left i look at her
you know she's she's not old yet she's
not midlife yet but you don't have that
many years left
and this isn't even that big a decision
whatever is in front of you is not
actually that big a decision there are
much bigger decisions ahead it may feel
like a big decision it may feel like it
but after you've done it and you get
through it you'll realize huh i could do
that again and there's another bigger
decision ahead you need to shorten the
gap between deciding that you want to do
something and actually taking action
towards it who you spend time with is
who you become it's why i created this
channel so you and i can hang out with
people like warren buffett you may never
meet warren buffett but you can learn
from him you can be inspired by him and
you can change your life for the better
by consuming this kind of content i love
modern success because i learned from
bill gates bill gates was the first guy
that i modeled success from i had a
software company was struggling was
making no money i told my partner i quit
and then i asked myself somebody has
done this before i can't be the first
person to try to build a software
company it can't be this hard please
somebody's figured this out and the only
person who came to my mind was bill
gates who started microsoft i hadn't
been really that interested in reading i
hadn't been that interested in studying
success i was just trying to come up
with ideas myself and i was desperate
right i told my partner i quit i was
desperate i was at rock bottom and so i
said somebody's figured this out i can
only think of bill gates at microsoft
and so i studied his company and how he
started the zero to one right how did he
make his first million what did he do
and it was through partnerships and i
applied that strategy to my business and
and shortly after i had my first deal
for 13 and a half thousand dollars and i
felt like i won the lottery
and after that i had a pattern to use
over and over and over again and since
then it's been 20 years now of sharing
that with you guys it's been for me
constantly learning it's the name of my
channel model and success it's why i
have all these people behind me on the
wall that's why i make these videos
every day it's why i love learning from
people like warren buffett and steve
jobs and kanye and oprah and all these
people
because they can shift you because they
shifted me and the thing that they give
you at least for me they give me one the
inspiration the motivation the idea that
look at what they started with that they
could start from there and end up at
this new place why can't i you you
already have more resources than bill
gates did when he started
you have more resources than kanye did
than steve jobs did when they started
you're in a better position than they
were they would have to create amazing
things go study oprah's story and tell
me that you're in a worse position than
oprah was when she started
you're not
you're not and so it's inspiration the
other part is tactics ideas specific
strategies right bill gates doing
partnerships through distributorships
all of these things learning from that
and saying hey i can apply that to my
business maybe not 100
but it gets you 80 of the way and
instead of you figuring out the entire
solution you just have to figure out how
to bridge that 20 gap at the end it's
much easier it can lead to your success
there is no longer any acceptable reason
why you can't get the mentors that
you're after and start winning the
opportunities that in front of you right
now did not exist for your parents and
it's only getting easier but you still
have to do your part you still have to
reach out you still have to want it it's
actually less about winning the lottery
and where you came from and much more
about how badly do you want it and how
much you're gonna put in to get after it
because if you are willing to put in the
work you can beat out somebody with a
thousand times more resources than you
so every night i go on twitch and i
stream my league of legends games
twitch.tv believe team here and there
was a guy who joined me last night from
the philippines he's from the
philippines and he says that his goal is
to be a professional league of legends
player and the challenges is not a big
league of legends scene in the
philippines there's no professional
teams there's only one player right now
named like smithy who's a jungler where
did he go he was jungler for team liquid
and he signed with a new team it escapes
me right now there's one person who was
born in the philippines who's a pro
player right now mix is living as a
professional league of legends player
this guy joins my live stream last night
and he says he's a support player from
the philippines and that's his ambition
he's going to grind it out he wants to
get noticed he wants to get picked up he
wants to be a professional league of
legends player
the crazy thing is that's actually
possible it's actually possible for him
to do it it's actually possible for him
to get training for him to get
mentorship for him to reach out to for
him to get in contact with people here
he is he's in philippines i'm in canada
and we're talking and we're connecting
on my live stream
it's actually possible it wasn't
possible even 10 years ago definitely
not for his parents you look at what his
parents are doing where they came from
you could have some dream but at that
time the gym was probably just to come
to north america or just to have this
one little thing that that existed in
the world currently right this limited
mindset because there were limited
opportunities but right now the
opportunities are insane you have a
thing called the internet
people didn't have it before the
opportunities are insane you are
competing against the world which is bad
for a lot of north americans
but it's amazing for everybody who's
outside or amazing for anybody who's
willing to work hard it's not even bad
for north americans it's bad for anybody
who's
lazy who's slow who's maybe had things
handed to them there's a lot of people
in north america who had nothing handed
to them but they're willing to work hard
if you are willing to work hard if you
are willing to show yourself it's never
been easier to win justin bieber got
discovered on youtube you don't need to
have a manager anymore you don't have to
go through the system you don't want to
i got a publisher for my deal but you
don't want to have a publisher you don't
publishers reject you great go off and
sell publish david goggins did lots of
people created number one bestsellers
just from self-publishing you can bet on
yourself if you're willing to work hard
if you're willing to put in the effort
it's never been easier to win and so i
look at this guy from the philippines it
might be easier for me right me sitting
here in canada
if my goal was to be a professional
league of legends player sure it might
be easier for me sure i might have more
resources sure i could afford coaching
and go to tournaments and meet people
but it's also never been easier for him
because
in the past it would have been only
available to me now it's available to
anybody and if he has the heart and the
hustle and the drive and the intention
and the will to go off and do it every
day
he can crush someone like me even if i
have a thousand times more resources
than him and you can too you are where
you are in life and business because of
your standards it's just not important
enough for you yet to hit that next
level for you for me for all of us we've
settled we've settled for what currently
is and haven't demanded from ourselves
that we reach that next level change
your standards change your life
so i was recently talking to alex on my
team
and he helps me run toronto dance also
the largest dance school for salsa in
north america probably and he recently
went through this weight loss challenge
and he lost i don't know i want to say
30 pounds
and now he's sticking to this really
thin
line of between 150 and 155 pounds
that's his goal that's the standard when
he's when he's getting close to 155 he
slows down on the eating and when he's
around 150 he has a little bit more and
he's constantly staying in this band
because he set a new standard for
himself even though he might have been
180 or 185 before
now anywhere close to 155 is gonna be
too much like that's it that's my new
standard that's the lowest i'm gonna go
which is crazy high compared to what he
was before he's now trying to bring that
same standard to his business so what
he's trying to do every day now is if
you follow him on instagram is he's
posting at the end of the day how proud
he is of the effort he put in
how proud is he of the effort that he
put in out of 10 and sometimes you see
it's 5.5 sometimes you see it's a seven
and every now and then it's an eight or
even a nine
how proud he is of the effort that he
put in this is now the area where he
needs to raise his standards and i was
talking to him yesterday in a big
breakthrough that happened was said alex
you lost 30 pounds man or more from your
weight loss journey now the idea of
being over 155 is crazy when you used to
be 180 right or 185 it's crazy you need
to take that same approach to your
business to your effort that you're
proud of yourself every day for what
you're doing anything under eight should
be considered a cheat day
anything under eight is like you had a
cheat day on your diet
every now and then on his weight loss
journey he had
a cheat day he had a moment of weakness
he he went for a giant pizza and a cake
because he was starving and he couldn't
control himself but it was these one-off
moments right it was like once every
three weeks or something and he
continued down
that now needs to be your daily effort
if it's under eight that's like you're
eating cake and pizza
it needs to be the new water line that
if you're getting close to it's like
holy cow i can't i need to work harder i
need to accomplish i need to go off and
do
just like 155 now is that benchmark for
himself and putting into those terms
made sense for him because he had higher
standards now for himself in what he ate
in how he took care of his body than he
did for what he was doing to his
business and so it's the same thing for
you you want to grow you want to get
better you want to improve you have to
raise your standards
you have to now not settle for where
you're at because where you're at is
good this is the problem good is the
enemy of great right where you're at
it's good it's good it's not amazing but
it doesn't suck because if it sucked if
you hated it every day you would have to
find a way out but because it's good you
don't do it you don't change
it's not important enough for you to
want to get to that next step most
people grew up with an unhealthy view of
money some people think that money is
everything that the next person you see
the next customer you talk to that's
your next suit that's your next car and
other people think that money is the
root of all
right or the love of money is the root
of all
evil right to make money you're evil
you're slimy you're gross you're ripping
people off most people grow up in one of
those two camps that's the lesson that's
been taught you by your parents the
truth is money is just a tool money is
an amazing tool that lets you accomplish
amazing things and if you are an
entrepreneur and want to have success
making money has to be in your top five
list of priorities if it is not in your
top five then you're not making money
but it can't be number one money can't
be your number one priority there has to
be something that is more important than
it and that's your purpose i don't
really usually talk a lot about money on
my videos um
maybe i should maybe i should talk more
about it i think it's important i think
there's just so much out there that
seems to be money money money money that
i'm trying to go against it to say like
purpose is number one you have you're
built to serve if you're just chasing
money you're never gonna win i think i
see too many entrepreneurs just chasing
money and so a lot of the content that i
make is more purpose-driven but there's
still
there's still i think a lot of people
who are purpose-driven who've started a
business for the right reasons and they
don't know how to make money and so
maybe i need to switch up some of the
content that i make as well to help
change the perspective around money my
personal view is i hate spending money
until i'm making money
i love making money it's not number one
right serving believing entrepreneurs is
number one
but again it's in the top five because
if i didn't make money i wouldn't have a
team i wouldn't have people to help me
make this video it'd be me by myself
trying to put together one piece of
content you know a week or maybe a day
just you know filming by myself but
instead i have this team of people who
i'm super appreciative of and i can
afford that because i'm making money
doing the business that i'm doing doing
what you are afraid of is your path to
success every time you take on something
new that scares you that pushes your
comfort zone that requires you to
stretch
on the other side of that scary thing is
the new you who is now capable of more
most people they shrink from scary
things
because they're scary but if you want to
win if you want to hit your ambitious
goals then you have to teach yourself
that you do scary things so i recently
came back from two pretty significant
speaking gigs uh in my career as i'm as
i'm building up and speaking on bigger
stages
the first was when i was speaking at
brendan burchard's event and it says
growth.com event and brendan one of the
greatest speakers in the world invited
me to come and talk to his group of
couple thousand people and then i went
to ed miletz event just recently in
whistler and this is a smaller group a
hundred so people but they pay 60 000 a
year to be a part of his program and so
they're coming to learn from the best he
sandwiched me
between david goggins and peyton manning
so it's david goggins and then me and
then peyton manning that was the lineup
and so
when i was backstage at the brendan
event
i remember moments before going on stage
i was the most scared that i'd been in a
long time the most nervous the most
anxious
i was afraid of disappointing people my
biggest fear is letting people down my
biggest fear is that i'm going to let
brendan down and dean grazios who they
both brought me there
and i was just going to suck on stage
that was my biggest fear and so i had a
mini panic attack backstage five minutes
before going out but i have this mini
panic attack and i'm forgetting what i'm
gonna say i i imagine myself going on
stage and just blanking out
and
i tell myself i'm evan carmichael i do
difficult things i love difficult things
if i don't do difficult things i'm never
gonna accomplish great things so i have
to do difficult things i love it i
thrive on difficult things
and then i remembered what i was gonna
say and then i went out and i did my
thing
and now when i went to ed's event
i wasn't as nervous i wasn't as afraid i
was still scared i was still afraid of
letting down at my left letting down
andy furcello who they both brought me
there
being between david goggins and peyton
manning and just being out sean
uh you know everybody knows them they
may not know me all of it all of the
fears and doubts but less than what i
had at brenden's event not because it
wasn't as big a deal but because i had
just done it
because speaking on stage a couple
thousand people at brenden's event and
having that panic attack and getting
through it
changed who i was
made me stronger made me more capable of
doing the next thing and the next thing
was ed's thing and so if i hadn't gone
to brennan's i would be terrified going
to ed's thing
so every time you take on these
difficult challenges
you might have the panic attack you
might have the anxiety inside you might
have that little voice to say you can't
do it what if you fail what if you
disappoint people what if you lose
respect what if it doesn't work out
but you know what's worse you know
what's worse than going up and failing
not trying
not doing it
finding some reason finding some excuse
to say you're sick you're busy you can't
make it but in the back of your head
you know you're just afraid and the last
thing you want to do is teach yourself
that when you are afraid that when you
have an opportunity in front of you and
you're afraid to do it that you say no
you don't want to teach yourself that
you teach yourself the opposite
that when you're afraid that when
there's something in front of you that
you want to do but you're scared you're
anxious you're worried about letting
people down
that you jump in
and you say i'm all in
because i do scary things most people
suck at creating work-life balance or
harmony because you're constantly
comparing what you're doing to other
people's schedules of all the things
that you need to figure out in life what
balance means to you is among the most
important jeff bezos jokes about
optimizing his tooth brushing routine
because he's trying to maximize his
efficiency while warren buffett reads
for five to six hours every day you
can't do both and you need to stop
comparing yourself to someone who you're
not it's crazy how much balance and
scheduling comes up
i think most people are lost i think i
think again the biggest problem is
you're just comparing yourself to other
people and then you don't know where to
stand you don't know what rock to stand
on and so you feel like you're pulled in
a thousand different directions when i
went on my tour this year and i'm sure
it's going to come up on the next one
again people kept asking that what does
balance mean to you how do i find
balance in my life and and i used to
joke one of the funniest jokes that i
told and i'm not that funny so this is
this is one of the funny moments um was
i was talking about the rock and the
rock has his routine where he's working
out for four hours a day he has to work
out for four hours a day and so when
he's doing his
movies he wakes up five hours before he
has to be on set and he'll work out for
his four hours and he'll do two times
cardio and two times weights and then go
to the you know go to his trailer shower
and then head head out to the movies and
he's only sleeping four to five hours a
night when he's on set
i think that's crazy but i don't look
like the rock and that's when people
would laugh because i don't look like
the rock but it's true
people will try to take on the rock
schedule but you have other priorities
what the rock values isn't the same
thing as you value there may be some
overlap and some similarities and
there's nothing wrong with trying on the
hat there's nothing wrong with
attempting to do it there's nothing
wrong with seeing how it fits right to
get pieces to say hey i'm gonna try
meditating i'm gonna try working out i'm
gonna try making a video i'm gonna try
morning pages i'm gonna awesome great
yes
but then to judge yourself to say well
i'm not able to stay consistent on that
it's not what you should be doing
because you want to work out four hours
a day and you want to read five hours a
day like warren buffet and you want to
optimize your toothbrush routine like
jeff bezos and you want to do all these
different things
but it's too many hours in the day what
you have to figure out is how does
balance look like for you and then not
be ashamed to go off and live it when
everybody else thinks you're nuts most
people never hit their goals because
they don't structure their life towards
actually accomplishing those goals you
can say that you want something you can
say that this is your ambition and your
goal but unless it's in your calendar
unless you start actually working
towards it you're never going to
accomplish it dreams stay dreams because
there is no momentum let's talk about
how to get it one of the common
questions i get asked when i'm doing my
live stream when i'm doing my my
interviews when i'm doing my my tour my
stops people almost always will ask me
how many hours sleep do you get when you
go to bed when you get up how much do
you sleep every night
right now i'm sleeping nine hours a day
i sleep nine hours i did a sleep study
i was sleeping around eight and getting
and was still tired when i woke up and
so i went and did an overnight sleep
study and he told me i'm looking for the
hack i'm like hey you're you're
deficient in magnesium so just take
these and you can sleep seven and be
normal
he said no nothing wrong with you you
just need to sleep nine hours a night
that's healthy for you like what that's
healthy are you kidding me what are you
talking about nobody sleeps nine hours a
night he's like yeah between six and ten
is actually that's the normal range the
whole eight hours a night is a myth
so
i felt bad and i'm still trying to hack
it so i sleep nine hours a night i don't
wake up to an alarm
and people assume that i am i'm only
sleeping
three four or five hours a night because
of how productive i am during the day
this is it right you could sleep 12
hours a night
and crush it in the other 12 hours most
people default to thinking they need to
wake up an hour really say well if i
wake up at 5 00 a.m or at 4 00 a.m i'm
gonna be more productive if you are not
productive for 16 hours a day
then adding an extra hour to that it's
not going to make you that much more
productive the problem isn't what time
you wake up the problem is what you're
doing with the hours that you're awake
and so as much as possible what i try to
do is make every second intentional i'm
not always able to achieve that
especially not every second but
but i try to make everything intentional
i try to make every where i'm spending
time is intentional i'm in the present
i'm not thinking about something else
i'm here with you guys making this video
right now all i think about is this
video that i'm making for you right now
where is nina right now i don't know
where's my cell phone
well it's right here because i can see
it but where are my keys i don't know
where my dogs i don't know what am i
doing after this i have no idea
i'm focused and i'm with you right now
most people live in the past most people
are thinking about what could have been
most people are regretting the decisions
that they made and they're
procrastinating because they're afraid
of doing things because they don't want
to do things
all things that prevent you from
actually doing
that's the biggest problem you're a
genius
you're the best in the world at
something you can go off and make
amazing things the problem is your time
is not being used efficiently
it's not being used effectively either
you haven't structured your life
to help you accomplish your goals look
at your big goals look at your big goals
like what's the next big goal that you
have for yourself you may not have one
if that's that if you don't have one
then you got to figure out what your
purpose is because that's the greatest
thing of all time right get the book
built the serve you'll figure it out
you'll be you'll be ignited
but your next big goal
now look at your calendar are you
aligning
what's in your calendar your daily
habits towards you accomplishing your
goals for most people it's it's now or
you're you have it listed but you're not
doing it because you look at it and you
get afraid and you procrastinate on it
so trying to cut that down to almost
zero even before making these videos
before making espresso videos i have
a couple minutes of procrastination
um i go and make sure i get my water
i go and maybe have a keto bar just
pacing around a little bit because i'm
nervous about making the videos because
i want them to be the best videos that
i've ever made it's always my intention
but too many people live in
hours or days or months of
procrastination instead of doing it you
get the results by doing it's the only
way you will never get the results by
just thinking about it you can be
motivated amazing have the mindset
awesome that's half the equation the
other half is doing you have to actually
just go out there and do you need to
structure your life
to allow you to accomplish your goals
the biggest mistake so many
entrepreneurs make is they jump into a
business because they see that it's a
hot opportunity you don't love it you
don't know much about it but so many
people are talking about it and it looks
like an easy way to make a lot of money
big
mistake don't do that it's the fastest
way to go broke so warren buffett did
not invest in amazon but he's still done
pretty well for himself he didn't invest
in amazon because he doesn't like tech
he doesn't know it he doesn't love it he
doesn't live in that space and so he
doesn't want to buy those kinds of
companies and great he missed out on
amazon but he also missed out on all the
tech companies that didn't make it that
he could have put money into that just
would have gone to zero he knows what
he's great at he knows what he loves and
he sticks in his arena a look at what
i'm doing there's so many opportunities
that come my way that i know nothing
about i have no interest in i don't want
to have interest in that i'm i'm losing
money on right
i don't like real estate i hate real
estate i don't want to i want to be in
it i don't want to learn about it i
don't like real estate it's not that
it's not a good opportunity it's just
not for me it's boring to me i have zero
interest in real estate it's great for
so many people so many people have built
amazing wealth and generational wealth
based off of real estate amazing i'm
pumped for you it's just not the thing
that i want to be in
cryptocurrency right people when bitcoin
was taken off everybody was a
cryptocurrency expert
i know nothing about cryptocurrency i've
bought zero cryptocurrency in my life
i've been given zero cryptocurrency in
my life
is cryptocurrency the future yep when is
it gonna come i don't know is it gonna
be bitcoin i don't know i i don't know
anything about cryptocurrency i get the
mechanics and the general theory and i
know that it's coming
but it's not the opportunity for me
cbd is a big thing now right everybody's
getting into cbd and cbd oils and cbd
products and great and it's becoming
legal here in canada it already is legal
in a bunch of our provinces and it's
going to be legalized across many states
if not the whole country
awesome
it's not me i don't i don't i'm not in
the cbd i don't i don't smoke any
marijuana i never have i'm not
interested in it it may help you it may
alleviate your pain amazingness may be
the greatest gift you've ever seen in
your life amazing but if you're only
jumping into it because you think it's a
hot opportunity you're gonna lose
that being said i'm also involved in so
many things that are hot opportunities
i'm drowning in opportunities i have too
many opportunities that i know what to
do with let alone don't know what to do
with looking at youtube youtube right
now is still a massive opportunity
there's so many people who look at what
i've done who look at what gary have
done and grant cardone and those guys
have done and say i want to do it
youtube is blowing up it's popping it's
exploding if you're a thought leader if
you want to have educational content
youtube is still a huge opportunity most
people who are the experts at what they
do are not on youtube
that means you can go on even with a
little bit less expertise and go and
crush it because the people who are the
best in the world are doing it they're
not doing it it's a huge opportunity
it's a big white space still right now
even though i've been on it for 10 years
youtube has evolved a lot over the past
decade and there's still tons of white
space open and available i need to push
the opportunity harder i look at thought
leadership as another one thought
leadership the stuff that i'm doing the
videos like this the teaching that i've
done the workshops that i've done people
want to be a thought leader not just an
influencer but a thought leader
and i'm at the center of that trend i'm
helping train a lot of thought leaders
people are coming to me asking me for
help in becoming a thought leader in
making content and being able to do good
videos and be able to get speaking gigs
book deals all of it people want it it's
happening and i'm at the center of that
trend too
league of legends
i love league of legends i've been
playing league of legends for
this is six years this is my sixth year
playing league of legends i played teemo
look i got i got i got teemo here i got
teemo here i got tristana here i've
named my dogs timon tristana right i
play
three games a night on my twitch stream
you can come to my twitch stream
twitch.tv
believe team come join me i play there
three games a night i'm trying to get
the gold uh this season which means i'm
in the top 10
of players uh in north america so that's
my it's my ambition for the year i watch
league of legends every weekend i have a
tsm jersey let me get it
i have a tsm jersey i'm a fan i love
league of legends i love esports
if you are getting into esports
just because it's a hot opportunity and
you don't love it you're gonna die
you're gonna lose
i look at garyvee as an example and
gary's done an amazing job in hip-hop
an amazing job in hip-hop and he's
brought so many different artists on
from the top of nipsy hustle all the way
down to people were just breaking in and
trying to get their start he loves
hip-hop he loves the lyrics he loves the
culture and so he's really built a name
for himself inside of hip-hop he got
into twitch a little bit he had a twitch
studio set up in his office and he
started doing a little bit of gaming but
he's not a gamer he hasn't done gaming
in decades and so it's not authentic for
him and so he's not gonna win there i
love esports i love league of legends i
love gaming it's part of what i do i can
talk to you about the current roster for
tsm and my thoughts on it i could talk
about the new patch that came out on
league of legends and how teemo is doing
i like it it's just i i genuinely like
it and so i have these opportunities in
front of me already within youtube
within thought leadership within esports
that that i can take advantage of and
blow up in and i don't need to worry
about real estate and cryptocurrency and
cbd and all the other millions of
opportunities out there there's already
tons of opportunities inside the things
that you already know and love the
things that you know and love there's
lots of people who know and love that
thing too
and they're looking for guidance they're
looking for help they need answers you
could be the person who gives them the
answers
jumping on some train because you think
it's a hot opportunity and a chance to
make money is the fastest way that you
will lose money because you don't
understand anything about that if you
don't love esports don't go spend money
on an esports team
you're gonna lose you don't even know
what you're doing
inside the things that you love and know
is a tremendous opportunity and that's
what you need to focus on
if you want to go brick by brick to make
it stick you have to pay attention to
two critical pieces the first is mindset
the second is action you need both or
you're gonna give up on your goals you
know you're capable of something bigger
but you'll give up because you don't
have these two simple things settled out
i'm gonna show you how to fix them in
this video step number one is mindset
what you think you're capable of is what
you're actually capable of if you think
you can go off and do it you're much
more likely to do it but if in your head
no matter how many skills and resources
and people are telling you you're great
if in your head you don't believe you
can do it guess what's going to happen
you're not going to do it and so you can
apply brick by brick in a methodology
that i call big y little y your big why
is the big reason why you're doing this
thing why are you doing this thing your
purpose comes from your pain you got a
big goal big ambition you want to change
the world you have to have a huge impact
right you want to solve giant problems
and change people's lives right that's
your big why
you want to put a dent in the universe
right you want to you want to make an
impact that's beyond your lifetime it's
a huge why
i'm waking up trying to solve the
world's biggest problem i don't think
people believe in themselves enough i'm
trying to solve the world's biggest
problem i think that's the world's
biggest problem i'm never going to solve
it even if i touch a billion people i'm
never going to solve it that's the best
i think you should wake up and have a
big why so big that you're never going
to accomplish it you're going to climb
forever you're going to be on your
journey forever forever forever it's the
best
and oftentimes that big mission that big
vision you have is so motivating for you
that it gets you out of bed gets you
motivated like let's go here's what i'm
trying to do and it gets you pumped up
but
sometimes the big picture is too big
sometimes your big y right it's big y
little y sometimes the big y is so big
that you feel you can't do it
that you're not capable that you don't
have the skill sets that you'll never be
capable and so you throw in the towel
because it seems too big
and i get that too you know i'll look at
me and my goals of solving the world's
biggest problem and say who am i to
solve the world's biggest problem
right how how i capable of going off and
doing that
and especially in my i'm trying the last
time that you thought about that
especially in my earlier years as an
entrepreneur i really struggled with
that i'd go do a speaking gig and and be
so fired up and so motivated like man i
know i'm crushing it i'm helping people
so much it's amazing this is this is
oxygen this is what i'm breathing is
amazing thank you so much
and then i wake up the next day and be
back to normal like oh can i do this i
don't know if i can do this
because there's lack of momentum
and so that's where the little y's come
in and the little why is the reminder
that what you do is important i think
it's i think it's so important that you
feel that the work that you do is
important
if you woke up and felt every day the
work you do matters means something is
having an impact
man the commitment level you're gonna
have is so much greater than if you feel
like nobody cares what's the big deal
meh right so how do you remind yourself
that the work you do on a daily basis is
important to at least one person that's
the little why the big why's the big
vision big dream big big mission like
where you're going awesome the little
why is you may not be able to help a
billion people but you can help one
just reminding yourself that you helped
one person how i get that now is in my
youtube comments even now as part of my
morning routine i go to my youtube
comments and i just see what people are
saying
and these are people that you you know
amazing people who many many of whom
i've never met and maybe never will meet
hopefully hopefully i'll meet you come
on my tour meet me on tour probably i
won't meet most of you
and to see the warmth and the love and
the and the comments that you guys are
leaving makes me feel like this is why i
do it this is why it matters this work
matters if i stop doing this
it would it would mean something to
people and you'd have to go somewhere
else now not so full of myself that you
couldn't find another solution but the
work that i do matters and your comments
feed me every day
i'm spoiled now that we get hundreds of
comments and tons of dms and lots of
messages that come in daily but when i
was first getting started
i didn't get that many when i talked
about my early days as a speaker i would
speak and have a great time and then the
next day wake up and feel like what's
the point i would say the thing that
made the difference was i would save the
messages that people sent me
or emailed me or said at the end of one
of my workshops and i would put them
together in a powerpoint file and i
would watch that powerpoint file every
morning that became part of my morning
routine this is when i really first
started doing morning routines this is
this was such an important piece for me
was showing the messages from these
people
as a reminder every day that
what i do makes a difference and maybe i
will never hit my billion
but
these 18 people that i helped i helped
them that was me i did that right if you
felt like you helped some people
every single day even if just
remembering old people that you helped
every day as a reminder it'll give you
the ammunition the momentum the fuel
that you need to keep going every day so
brick by brick sometimes it's big y
right it's the mindset sometimes it's
the big why sometimes it's just man i'm
gonna go crush the world i'm so excited
i'm gonna go solve this giant problem
and and change humanity right sometimes
you feel like that and it's amazing and
you go you go you use that boldness and
energy to create something amazing
and sometimes you're gonna feel like i
can't do that big thing and so you just
look at the comments you look at the the
one person that you helped or the five
people that you helped or think back the
people that you have helped in your life
to remind yourself that you are valuable
that you make a difference that the work
you create is meaningful and to get the
momentum and energy you need because for
the most part the biggest thing you're
missing is just momentum and momentum
comes from mindset if you believe you
can create great things you can so brick
by brick starts with mindset big y and
little y so i said there were two things
right there's mindset and then there's
action so step number two is action so
you you think you can do something then
you have to go off and do it thinking it
is not enough you got to do something
you got to act on it and brick by brick
here is we often will plan this giant
thing right you have this bold vision
this big idea amazing and you default
into planning mode and you think i got
to do this and this and this and this
and this and this and this and this and
it's exciting and it's fulfilling it's
amazing to think in planning mode of
what you can potentially build but then
you step back and look at that behemoth
that you just built
in your head or on paper and you think
wow that's really big
to do that i need i need venture capital
i need partners i need i need i need a
team i need and all this all this stuff
that you need that you don't have
and then that becomes scary and then you
don't act and so i believe what i call
the two percent difference the two
percent difference is as soon as you
come up with an idea
we're taking immediate action on the
first two percent so what we typically
do is we'll plan to get to one hundred
percent you'll plan to 100 you'll plan
your your entire vision out until it's
complete right
then that becomes too scary instead of
planning as your first step plan is
important but it's not the first step
your first step is action your first
step is doing your first step is the
first two percent what is the first two
percent version so if your plan is to
build the next youtube channel it's
going to dominate the world i love it
it's easy to think well i'm the camera
person i need a team i need an editor
and i need a script writer i need i need
i need i need a need
great awesome two percent difference
take your phone make a video today teach
yourself to go from idea to action idea
action the smallest possible version
that little video you make from your
phone what difference it's gonna make
not a lot in terms of output but a ton
in terms of momentum
a ton in terms of momentum most people
just don't start if you want to lose
weight you want to get in shape the best
thing you can do is do 10 push-ups right
now i had a person in one of my lives
who said that their goal was to to get
in shape okay great
go do 10 push-ups right now don't don't
come back on into the live until you've
done 10 push-ups
are those 10 push-ups going to actually
make that person lose 20 pounds of
course not
but the difference between no push-ups
and 10 push-ups is the whole game
because if they do that 10 push-ups they
taught themselves to go from idea to
action idea to action idea to action
that's the thing that's missing for most
people you have great ideas i believe
you have michael jordan level talent at
something you're not acting enough not
in a big enough way not consistently
enough there's too much time planning
and thinking and over analyzing and
worrying about judgment instead of just
getting out there and actually doing
so planning is important it's just not
the first step you burn all of your
boldness and creativity and energy on
the planning and you wake up the next
day and you think i can't go do that big
scary crazy thing
or instead as soon as you get the idea
the best thing you can do with your
energy with your boldness with your
confidence in that moment in that idea
that you just created is go do something
about it and teach yourself that you're
the kind of person who comes up with
great ideas who trust their great ideas
who doesn't over analyze anymore and
just puts them out into the world and
builds momentum that's going brick by
brand because you made it this far in a
video i want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you're
special believe nation you made it here
all the way to the end and i love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
below on this video i will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome if you want to watch another top
10 rules of evan carmichael check out
the video next to me
continue to believe i will see you there
the problem is people compare themselves
to others as a way to kick themselves
down you look at somebody else who's
done a lot more than you and you say wow
there's so much better than me i can
never do it